Elon Musk has fired his election
Integrity team for compromising the
Integrity of the election who would have
seen this one coming uh it's fantastic a
lot of people were worried when it was
announced that X would be bringing on
the same old garbage and many of these
people this is really funny because one
of these Apparently one of these
election Integrity guys was making fun
of me and people were like I'm I'm
concerned about the bias of this team
when they're engaging in partisan
attacks on you know social commentators
and things like that but uh he fired
them that's interesting and we'll talk
about that we got other big news this
one's fascinating in the case where the
judge summarily ordered Trump to
dissolve the Trump organization insane
right he values Mar-A-Lago at about 18
to 20 million dollars despite the fact
that Mar-A-Lago generates 25 million
dollars per year something's not right
yet for whatever reason reasons you
probably understand Democrats and
leftist personalities are agreeing with
the judge
this is crazy the Trump family the same
this this property is probably Worth
close to a billion dollars and if you
look at comparables in the area based on
real estate alone and not a business
they are correct you got a half acre
going for 40 million dollars and
Mar-A-Lago is Beach to Beach property so
we'll talk about that but my friends
it's uh it's the bait night so around
9pm the lesser-known GOP debate will
begin where we will waste our time but
make fun of Republicans who aren't going
to be the president and I guess we'll
we'll enjoy our time doing so before we
get started head over to timcast.com
click timcast irlx Miami pick up your
tickets while you still can we are going
to be in Miami all next week Friday
October 6th we will be live with Patrick
Bet David James O'Keefe Matt Gates Ian
will be there of course I will be there
Luke gradkowski will also be there plus
many special guests we're gonna have
Alex Stein doing a stand-up bit a
pre-show and we're gonna have an after
show just for the people who are at this
event plus a bunch of free gear and I
believe right now we haven't yet
formalized it but it is looking like
that Friday night show will be a Tim
cast members only exclusive for a
variety of reasons in fact I think the
daily wire uh with Michael knows here
you know exactly why we're doing it you
you did the same thing recently with
your backstage yeah when yeah I saw your
video you put out where you were saying
we're going to take this normally on
YouTube we're gonna put it so we're
doing this event and uh that whole show
it's going to be 100 times better for us
to be on stage with the audience
everybody watching participating and not
having to worry about the BS plus it's
just a way for us to help make more of
these events make it function make it
reasonable so definitely uh get your
tickets while you can't why you still
can and also uh click join us become a
member and you get access to our Discord
server to hang out with like-minded
individuals they run their own pre-shows
after shows midday shows they're working
on projects games card games all this
really awesome stuff if you want to be a
part of it help build culture another
good reason to become a Tim cast member
and as a member you can submit it
questions to the uncensored show Monday
through Thursday and call in and talk to
us and the guest however I do believe
because of the GOP debate tonight we
likely will not have a members only show
we'll just do an extended show where we
probably just make fun of Republicans
who are not going to be president that
being said joining us tonight to talk
about this and so much more is Michael
Knowles great to be with you as always
I'm really glad that I could be here
because you get accused of leaning in
favor of one candidate or maybe another
candidate and I just think Doug burgum
does not get nearly enough support on
this show so I'm here for the
bergamentum which starts tonight
did you coin the bergamento the
bergamentum is the successor movement to
the chrysosons or croissants for short
for Mr Christie that has not really
taken off so now we're on to bergmendum
uh and I think everybody knows who you
are but uh do you want to give a brief
introduction yes I'm the only Republican
not running for president this cycle and
I have just as much of a chance as every
guy who's on stage uh but you won't see
me on stage you can find me at the
Michael Knowles show and elsewhere right
on uh well thanks for hanging out we got
Mary Morgan hanging out hello everyone
it's been a minute since I've been on
IRL uh and I'm back and I'm happy to be
here I work at timcast up in the attic
on pop culture crisis we don't really
get into politics we talk about
Hollywood celebrities that kind of thing
uh so yeah I guess I'm gonna have to
talk about politicians we do have a
crane and maybe but we do six yes but we
do have a story that overlaps because
Joe Biden called out Cool J boy
he confused him for Corn Pop In fairness
had he known what a great guy is as bad
as it sounds no it's really not he the
headline sounds bad it sounds like he
was talking to LL Cool J and he goes hey
boy but that's not that's not really
what happened either way I mean I guess
a lot of people are a lot of left-wing
people are angry that in whatever
context but we'll talk about it so yeah
you know whatever we got in here hi
everybody Ian Crossland happy to be back
happy to see you guys hello Michael
those headphones are fire Mary nice work
thank you I like them can can they see
that the yeah oh yeah those light up
yeah yeah
subtle right tasteful yeah we'll just
have to turn the lights on
well hello hi Serge how you doing hey
I'm doing good nice shirt again man
thanks man it's sick I'm a fan uh
search.com let's get started Tim we got
this story from the post millennial
breaking Elon Musk fires X election
Integrity team for undermining election
Integrity ah this was just too good this
is big news considering we're entering
the cycle we got a debate tonight so I
figured let's let's jump into this one
Elon Musk announced on Wednesday that he
has cut the Electoral Integrity team at
X in half including the newly brought on
board uh board head of the group Aaron
rodorex when the news was reported musk
replied Oh you mean the election
Integrity team that was undermining
election Integrity yeah they're gone is
this like wow you remember when Trump
invited Mitt Romney to have dinner and
he said hey mitt maybe I'll make you
Secretary of State and he just
humiliated Mitt Romney at this dinner
there's that picture of trump grinning
like the Cheshire Cat and Romney kind of
you know cowered over is that just what
Elon does to these employees he says oh
yeah I'm gonna hire a bunch of election
Integrity be it sensors and you're fired
boom I wonder I wonder how much of this
is 5D chess or I don't know three how
many dimensions are we getting it's 3D
changes yeah right so Elon Musk goes to
war against the ADL because they're
trying to get advertisers well Elon
knows he's got to push back
how much do you want to bet some of
these advertisers or what companies were
like your platform is undermining
election integrity and then he goes
we're actually hiring an election
Integrity team to make sure that doesn't
happen they went oh okay he brings them
in gets evidence of them screwing with
the election right and then says you're
fired and now he can go here you go we
actually we are so so now Elon can say
no no we are actually upholding election
Integrity we fired these people that
were doing all of these things
maybe maybe I'm overestimating Elon no
no I think Elon if anyone on Earth right
now is playing 5D chess as they talk
about it it's Elon and you can see it in
the way he's handled by the Alex Jones
Band and he hasn't unbanned Alex Jones
account Alex actually is the one who's
like he's playing 5G chess if he unbans
me all the hate of the vehements of the
world will come unto him right now it's
on me we want to leave it on me and Elon
knows that so that's what he's doing is
Alex in the room right now did I channel
that beast wow so I think Elon very I
mean you've got to be at that level to
be firing Rockets up into space and
working on National Security and stuff
and I mean he's basically
he's veering the momentum of the Ukraine
Russia war in a lot of ways by shutting
down uh starlink over top of Ukraine
last year he didn't shut it down he
never turned it on he never turned it on
yeah so he denied service to a military
to a country during a war so like this
guy's got amazingly powerful um
influence and I think he's behind the
scenes just that they love him I think a
lot of like the arms manufacturers love
him I think that like yo if we need some
a corporatist to be running the world at
least it's Elon yeah I'm now Pro Elon I
was I was always I was never anti-elon
but I was sort of Elon skeptical because
I just wondered if he was the monorail
salesman from The Simpsons I didn't know
if it was all kind of a con and but well
but it it somewhat is I get but but he
he just keeps winning you know like he
whenever you think well they've got him
now kind of like Trump they've got him
now and then he just pulls a rabbit out
of a hat and and lives to see another
day yeah I think Elon has his agenda
he's clearly working towards a goal he
has in mind it just happens to overlap
greatly with the rest of us yeah and so
that works and then you see some of the
stuff that's going on with you know
China and you know Tesla factories there
and you're like yes Elon has an Elon
agenda but it benefits us so it's like
you know I think I wouldn't I wouldn't
describe Elon as evil I would actually
say we're we're mostly aligned he cares
about free speech he cares about what's
true he wants a platform where you know
Community notes is fact checking the
fake news in the media because he wants
truth but I think his politics
very much aligned with many left-wing
people yeah he talks about it quite a
bit yeah that's true he notes has kind
of ruined satire on the platform though
because it just tells you the joke yeah
yeah it's just a joke explainer at this
point and and I I actually I'm not a I
like Community notes a lot but I got
some criticisms because one thing that
happened was
I put out a tweet
criticizing uh I guess you call it
criticizing but pointing out that the
Rhonda Sanders campaign had used footage
from uh that we so it's complicated but
a lot eliahu reports for timcast however
he owns the the rights after the fact so
we get first rights on all the content
and then he can do whatever selling them
outside the company but we get first
rights to distribute them and so when
the Defenders campaign put out videos
with our video that we had that we had
got first rights on and then put paid
for by the tennis campaign it was
literally just this clip seven seconds
long nothing else there was nothing in
it wasn't an ad it was a video shot by
Allahu saying he paid for it and then I
asked him I was like hey did you sell
this and he's like no and I'm like okay
well like we didn't sell it to him yeah
so I tweeted we did not sell this to the
tennis campaign or whatever and what
they did was in my tweet pointing out
the clip they sent out to people via
text was was not paid for by the tennis
campaign the DeSantis people used
Community notes to change the context of
what was said to create fake news make
the insinuation was that the screenshot
I had posted was a full-length
advertisement and not a single clip
right right of course my point being hey
they're sharing a clip from our news
channel and then saying paid for by
DeSantis on the video which they did not
do then they put in community notes
advertisements in the political space
must say that they were I'm like it
wasn't an ad that's my issue with you
know Community because the community
notes are in a way like democracy which
is they're only as good as the community
noters you know it's only as good as the
people and so a lot of times it's pretty
good but then yeah sometimes people game
the system
yeah yeah right just like Wikipedia yeah
yeah I got this one the best community
note I ever saw it says Tim pool is bald
it was in response to help I'm being
Cyber Bullied tweet from last month do
you remember tweeting that out it was
something funny I can't the original
post was lost no I think it's inverted I
think I respected because supporters was
saying like Tim's not even bald and then
the community note
it's only half true because like yes
some some your balls
so you should know a community note on
the community note say a fact jacket
Temple wears a hoodie or a beanie rather
this goes full circle though because the
do so what happened was uh someone
pointed out that one of Twitter's
election Integrity guys was was
insulting me and it was him saying
something like you know if Temple had
hair I don't know I don't remember what
he said someone responded with that
stupid Temple's not even bald then
someone Community noted it saying Temple
is bald and then I quote tweeted the
Twitter Guy saying help help I'm being
separate
that was the best one of the best things
but this guy got fired this is the guy
I'm pretty sure this guy uh Aaron rodder
because that was him he got fired he's
gone and but but I think I think he got
fired because I mean dude you hire a guy
who then immediately goes on an activist
tirade across the board just insulting
people and
your boss is going to be like dude what
are you doing yeah yeah that's I I favor
the 5D chess a little bit here because I
don't know I just get the sense that
Elon knows what's up and he he goes
along and he plays games and he manages
to survive but do you does anyone really
believe that Elon Musk thinks Twitter
needs an election Integrity bizarre no
way when you put up that job posting
like you have complete control over
election related discourse on one of the
biggest social media platforms what kind
of person does that attract who's
sending in their resume maybe it was a
Honeypot you know Elon Musk is like come
control elections and then he sees who
comes in and he's like I got you it's
just a big bear trap on the other side
that's right
or but but now you know maybe he's like
look we have all this documentation of
firing these people was upholding
election Integrity I mean he still has
some people there
I think he only cut half of the team
right but he fired he said the election
Integrity team that was undermining
election Integrity they're gone what do
you guys think I guess he's saying
they're they're all gone that's what it
sounds like yeah what do you guys think
about moving shows over to x a lot of
people creators have been doing that
lately does daily wire
messed it at one point Walsh had to
because he got booted off of YouTube
whereas he was he was I think it was he
was demonetized then they shut me down
for a week from publishing then they
shut Candice down for a week then they
got me I sort of got out of jail a
little bit and then I think Matt got out
of jail too I don't know about Candace
so it they're just playing games all
it's always constantly moving which
means even if you're up on YouTube this
week we need an alternative long term
and so we've tried X formerly known as
Twitter and it's good we're putting the
shows up there it's nice to have a spot
to do it but you know they just haven't
worked at The Kinks do you guys watch
45-minute shows on right they need a
user friendly yeah it doesn't have like
to the next video it doesn't have to do
related videos do they yeah they they
that rolled out recently the swipe to
the next video and you can now do 2x so
they're remembering it skip ahead skip
back 15 seconds that's a key part of the
player I think Elon needs to do cash
deals Rumble is doing this Rumble is
teaming up with people and saying we
will pay you up front for you to start
building a base on Rumble and it's it's
it's masterful I mean they've got Street
League Skateboarding so for me
skateboarding I'm like they got Street
when I found out they got Street League
I was like whoa that's big mainstream
pop culture stuff exclusive now on
Rumble that's crazy and then I watched
the skate video with one of the top Pros
in the world and this is not political
stuff and they got rumble on their wall
in their skate park and I'm like this is
the move I think Elon doing the ad
sharing brilliant very very powerful
move I think the verification checks
people don't understand why this is such
an important thing that Elon Musk did
with uh Twitter blue so 10 years ago all
of these digital websites uh we'll leave
them nameless they would do something
like ad right something called add
rights sales where
a company would go uh like a company
that does clickbait garbage you may have
seen them where it's like 25 pictures of
gross celebrities and each picture is a
new page 800 ads on it so what those
websites would do is all those ad hits
count as ad Impressions and then one
click turns into 25 times 10 ads then
with all those ad hits they sell the
rights to a Big Brand let's you know
call it uh the daily fire or something
yeah just to pick one yeah pick one
random nonsense name but no the daily
wire literally doesn't do this I'm not
trying to I'm saying like a company
would then go to a slim cast something
like that goes to this company and says
we want to own the rights to Those ads
and and claim them and then what happens
is if you get 10 million views they sell
you the rights to those other views and
now slimcast has 80 million views you
then go to your advertise and say the
slimcast network gets 80 million it's
total BS right right what Elon Musk is
doing is going to advertising saying
when someone's season ad and there's a
check mark it is a real human for a
while the concern has been that
advertisers are all being ripped off by
Foreign Farms bot Farms that will make
fake traffic to generate ad sales and
then people are buying ads and they're
wondering why they're not working
it's being ripped away so what this has
actually done is it's made ads more
valuable so it's becoming more expensive
to advertise but the ads have bigger
returns so it's actually keeping
basically what's happening is when a
company would buy ads on these big Tech
platforms half of the money is going to
India or turkey where these Farms
operate out of what with what Elon is
doing is it keeps those ad dollars in
country where there's real people who
are verified
that's why the ad sharing thing is
working it's a good idea long story
short or more to the point I should say
Elon needs to get to the next next phase
where he goes to prominent high profile
individuals and says how much do you
want for your show to be an exclusive X
show yeah we advertise it Time Square
Billboards TV commercials YouTube ads
you name it that's the move they got to
make is there a way that Elon can fix it
I'm glad that they're doing the payouts
even though man I look at some people
they're just like buying cars with their
payouts I'm making pennies over here I
could barely afford a quarter pounder
with cheese with my payouts but it's
okay it's good I'm getting can you have
you said publicly I haven't but I'll
break it here this is breaking news I
hope all the journalists are writing it
up uh my first payout
was right when I signed up was like
eight or nine hundred bucks
and then it dropped to like 200 bucks
and it's like a hundred bucks but I'm
getting more Impressions it's not
impression based it okay yeah the the
money you get from X is based on how
many verified users interact with your
posts this is why you're seeing tons of
people ask questions so this is the
thing because I don't I don't engagement
bait you know I just kind of sometimes I
do accidentally so people don't like my
opinions but I don't I you're right the
people who are getting zillion dollar
payouts they all post things like you
know do you hate peanut butter and jelly
why yeah you know it adds value to the
ads but it has decreased the value of a
tweet to the point where my entire
timeline is just people reposting a tick
tock and being like what would you do in
this situation unfollow I can't yeah it
is that's wild you can make more money
but it's decreased the value the actual
human value of the post I think I'm
getting like five grand a month you're
getting five man I gotta get better
tweets what's going on
the internet when the program first
rolled out like a lot of the tweets
about it were in the east of
transparency
I'm I'm disclosing how much I'm making
off of Twitter ad revenue and it was
these crazy amounts like seventeen
thousand dollars I saw that that looked
insane and I just thought that those
were like paid sponsorships for X right
right I'm getting just shy six grand a
month what yeah I need to get some of
the you got to teach me how to get those
good five tweets well so all lower case
not a lot of like punctuation you don't
need that let me uh things that people
want to correct you know let me let me
let me try and find make an e-course so
like a paid ebook
to farm traffic but there's no a in the
word Farm I'm gonna be the new Andrew
Tate I think you know like how to get
rich quicker you're on the road I'm on
the road uh yeah I've got I need a
funnier accent and I have too much hair
but we were talking about your journey
to becoming Michael I'm gonna be a
hustler baby Michael this is what you
need to do okay you see this this is how
you make money on x
that year I I went on mid-journey and I
generated uh Donald Trump Whispering
sweet nothings to a chicken
and I posted it it's got 178 000 views
the next photo so I my mid-journey
journey was mostly centered around uh
pictures of Chris Christie as baked
goods because I really liked the pun of
the croissants and so I've got a a lot
of of like nice flaky Christy faces that
actually get Negative engagement I
actually owe Twitter money at the end of
the month because in in all reality
though like uh
I have a tweet I quote tweeted Libby
Emmons it's a it's a NYPD I'll just pull
the pull the Tweet up so you can see the
example so this is like real engagement
right like 2000 replies and it's the
NYPD police spot so it's like news stuff
but you know whatever I don't know I
don't really think about what I tweet I
just kind of Tweet stuff I'm gonna just
maybe I'll just copy your tweets I'm
just gonna take you're gonna tweet
something and then I'll just copy it and
post it and then be rich that's right
that's what I want all right well I I so
the reason why I quote tweet things a
lot is most of my retweets are just so
that I put I'm bookmarking them
basically I'll see a story and I'll be
like oh that's that's big I wanna I
wanna keep that in mind so I'll quote
tweet it like whoa and then I'll share
it yeah but quote tweeting turns a tweet
into your Tweet so it's now your
engagement a retweet it's their
engagement a quote tweet is your
engagement it seems like he's trying to
get rid of quote tweets though or at
least make them less accessible
every time I click on a Tweet now and I
try to look at the quote tweets oh yeah
that's true they're not visible or you
have to like press five different
buttons to get to like View Post
engagement because he probably wants you
to reply like it's all you know when
you're just trying to completely dunk on
someone with facts and logic yeah you
don't reply to them you you quote tweet
them right to send your army of minions
too to mob them yes which is much then
that's more fun the next step is when
you know when Tucker Carlson announced
he was doing that his show on X
everybody assumed it was a cash deal and
then Elon said no no no we're not doing
that
but if Elon came out and said like and
like he's wondering why Russell Brand
said all my shows are now on Rumble and
elon's like hey what about us we're
defending you it's like Elon dude
rumble's probably giving him eight
figures or something I don't know what
the deal is but they're they're probably
paying Russell Brand fat stacks to be on
Rumble Elon you can't just be like hey
what about me okay well how much am I
going to pay him they don't have an
exclusive deal with Russell Brando right
because he still has that like six
million following on YouTube it's a big
deal to walk away from that did you guys
but he got demonetized yeah did you
follow up yeah I heard that there's
Advertiser pressure on against Rumble
they're like they're the British
Parliament or something people were
trying to aim it what was that situation
Parliament sent a letter to the rumble
Executives and was like it was worded
like emotional terrorism like we would
like to know what you're doing to
protect alleged victims and you know
we're concerned about protecting the
Creator environment and we're concerned
that Russell Brand is making money off
of his content that has nothing to do
with his allegations I've been concerned
about like um advertisers polling and
trying manipulating social media markets
by being like you know if you if you
have that person on there we're not
gonna We're not gonna give our Ford
Automotive money to YouTube That's So
how it's been so it has been but mine's
just trying to figure out a different
way we have crypto that you can use
insights so you get rewarded for
activity inside you get crypto that you
can use in the site to boost your posts
it's kind of like because so this
outside force so like I hope X I hope
he's not too reliant on advertisers
because like he hired Linda yakarino and
I don't know her but I I've heard that
they're more concerned about like we
don't want crappy posts to be visible we
want the bad things to be hidden and the
good stuff to be seen because that's
what advertisers want let's let's let's
let's do a hard segue I really want to
talk about the story this is forbes.com
Trump family insists Mar-A-Lago worth
over one billion dollars after judge
calls value wildly inflated here's what
it might really be worth I'll give you
the gist the judge says it's worth
around 18 million dollars that's the
amount you make on Twitter every month
that's I I it's crazy right you know I
just as a humble a humble 18 million
um okay they say anger on the judge the
determination that Trump inflated the
value blah blah blah is uh based on an
appraisal from Paul Beach County
Assessor which found the market value of
the 17 and a half acre property between
2011 and 2021 to be 18 million and 27.6
million
let me first break down
what is absolutely insane about this
okay anybody who owns property knows the
tax assessed value is not what you list
the property for when you sell it right
so the idea that Trump is is being asked
what's it worth he's like well if I was
going to sell it I'd say 400 500 million
the tax assessor is saying 30 million
that's the tax assessor that's the
government that's their that's their
business Trump deciding it's worth more
it's not him inflating it the government
is in the Arbiter of the value of homes
just the taxation so look at I I gotta
tell you man this if this is true this
means every single home buyer has been
defrauded fraud of course so I'm I I'm
you know what this is awesome for me
because what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to take this judge's ruling in New
York I'm gonna go look at some New York
City real estate
two or two to three commercial acres in
Brooklyn with a tax assessed value of
200 000 and I'm gonna go to the person
selling it for five million and say if
you don't sell this to me for 200 000 I
will I will have you investigated for
fraud because the value according to
this judge is what the tax assessor says
not you sell it for 200 000 or else and
that strategy is going to work just so
long as the person you say that to is
the leader of the Republican party in
that election year then you're then
you're good exactly exactly but but no
like they'd be like screw up I'm not
selling you my commercial property for
20 000. okay then you go and complain
file a suit in this judge's court go to
the teacher James and say Here's your
opportunity to get Trump prove that you
really do think the property value is
what the tax assessor says and sell me
this hot five million dollar property
for two hundred thousand right I mean I
mean to be fair I wouldn't be able to
sell after that so I wouldn't want it
right true that would destroy the
property value of New York the thing
about Mar-A-Lago first of all is it's a
super nice club I've only gotten to go
once or twice and I was I expected it to
be kind of cheesy and gold and try it's
it's just a beautiful extremely well
established Club on beautiful property
but even put that aside for a second
a PO Box in Palm Beach is 18 million
dollars the notion that this very
prominent Club in the prime part of the
Prime Beach is is 18 million it's just
completely absurd yeah well I mean with
inflation in the last three years of
inflation if like yeah thirty percent
are currently 20 yeah like if something
was a dollar it's a dollar twenty now I
mean I don't know exactly the numbers
but like four years ago our national
debt was like 27. actually in now it's
34 trillion or something like that
that's I gotta I gotta build up the
value
this is Zillow and this is Mar-A-Lago
Mar-A-Lago goes Beach to beach it's got
water on both sides yeah oh it looks so
nice this so so I want you to understand
this whole plot right here and I believe
it might include this plot I'm not sure
who owns this one but this one doesn't
have a listing on it and they said it's
Beach to beach so I would I would
imagine it's probably trumps but I'm not
sure okay it says 24.2 million Zillow in
fact a few years ago it said 400. yeah
Zillow changed it apparently this is my
understanding I read an article that
said that I could be wrong I want to be
careful here but hold on
you see how big it is you see this itty
bitty thing right here
56.8 million wow something does not make
sense why is Zillow showing Mar-A-Lago
17.5 Acres as 24 million and then up
here literally next to Mar-A-Lago a much
much smaller property and much less
valuable because it's obviously not
beach to Beach right and it's double the
price wow so this property it's off the
market let's pull up the home details
it's uh 1.76 Acres
and its estimated value this I want to
make sure this is clear this is a Zillow
estimate not a market appraisal value
Zillow is saying this property is 56
million dollars but Mar-A-Lago is 24.
Mar-A-Lago is
17.51 Acres Beach to Beach and it's a
prop a club that generates 25 million
dollars per year right this little house
right here look at this this little itty
bitty house right here
is worth 2 million more than Mar-A-Lago
in what reality does look at this one
this tiny one right 30 million let me if
you if you pulled up here and said oh
this house is 30 million dollars
and then you look at Mar-A-Lago how come
I can't get the 17 Acres right sell me
that one that's cheaper that's insane
but but of course look there's no logic
to it we we could yell about it until
we're blue in the face they don't care
whatsoever the point of this ruling is
to say hey Trump we took away your
election perhaps and Trump we took away
some of your money and Trump were going
to take away your freedom because we're
going to put you in prison and now we're
going to take away your business just
cuz just because we want look at this
look at this right here
just just south of Mar-A-Lago on this
other side 100 million for for this
seven bedroom 100 million yo uh three
eight three and a half acres I'm
wondering what the ramifications of this
ruling is going to be because right now
the people who live in Palm Beach
all of them are angry that a judge just
ruled Marlo's worth 20 million because
now
yeah you're the you invested in property
in West Palm Beach thinking your value
is going to go up someone bought a
property for 20 million now the judge is
saying it's worth less than a million
dollars but forget I mean by The Way
West Palm Beach which is on the mainland
that property is worth a ton of money
we're talking about Palm Beach all right
right we're talking about the real job
West Palm Beach actual Palm Beach like
the number might make some sense in West
Palm Beach but it but it's all just a
forest no one no one takes this
seriously right no one takes the four
indictment seriously no it's it's just
Leticia James who who brought the case
ran for office saying I'm I'm gonna get
Trump this is all going on in New York
why they're talking about Trump's
property in Florida no one even really
knows it's just it's just a joke and the
sad part is
it might work right I mean well it's
going to work if you're in a communist
state where the law doesn't matter yeah
and so in the instant so let me show you
the suite from Kyle Kolinski
Kyle said Mar-A-Lago gets revenue of 25
million a year its value it's valued at
Max 75 million you idiots claimed it's
worth 739 million you did this with
virtually all of your properties to
inflate net worth and get loans from
banks on more favorable terms fraud
Kyle's completely wrong about all of
this yeah and it's shocking because I
like Kyle but this his his past few
tweets on all of this stuff shows that
he didn't actually look in any of it
first of all the Trump family valued the
property between 400 and 600 not 739
second why would the value of a 17 acre
piece of real estate a hard asset only
be valued based on the revenue generated
by the business right if you were to
remove the business outright we're
talking about a piece of property 17
acres in Palm Beach comparables are
would put the comparables of the of the
acreage just the acreage with no
property puts this property at a billion
dollars with no business on it right you
add 25 million a year we're probably
looking at 1.25 to 1.5 billion as a
business property
that's it's just simple the scary thing
about what Kyle is saying is that
his the point he made was that the the
uh Leticia James gave a press conference
that proves it
the judge then issued a summary judgment
with no trial sanctioned Trump's lawyers
banged the gavlin said dissolve the
Trump organizations you committed fraud
no trial no defense no evidence just a a
press conference and the judge says yes
and these people are celebrating it so
you know I was talking to
Andy no and he was asking if it was uh
wrong if I thought it was wrong that
people on the right keep calling the
left Communists because they call people
on the right fascist and I'm like well
the right's not fascist but the left is
communist and and I don't mean literally
every single person but there's the
banality of evil and malicious evil
there are people who are working in
service to Communism while not realizing
it and then there are people who are
literally doing it they make the same
argument on the right about fascism the
only problem is Dave Smith who they call
a fascist completely disagrees with
everything Trump does or 99 of it right
so you can't say he's in service
something he does he opposes outright
but this is the narrative they're going
with right now
and now they're actually just I'm I mean
I'm looking at this I tweeted in
response to what Kyle said Carl Benjamin
was just here said you were right they
eventually all just become Communists
they are now basically saying if the
state says so it is so and you know if I
mean one can talk about all the isms all
day long and and uh communism and
socialism are a consequence of
liberalism you know centuries ago but
even just the libs have this problem
which is liberalism boils down to
maximizing individual autonomy and what
that boils down to I mean we see this in
the absurdities of all the identity
ideologies that have proliferated today
but what that boils down to is a
diminishing of the importance of
objective reality of things like law of
things like I don't know real estate
prices relative to boundaries with all
of these things that that goes away I
mean if if a man can claim that he is a
type of thing that he is not and be
granted uh you know that that right in
society ID then we're untethered from
reality and so maximum individual
expression makes the law into nothing
more than a a way to wield a cudgel and
beat your enemies and and so we're going
to be debating about the law and the
objective value of this property but
they don't care they're just gonna
they're just gonna smack Trump and I'll
just just to add West Palm Beach point
three acre lot 5.5 million dollars point
point three wow so let's do 15 per acre
now do 17 acres and uh yeah but you know
I mean think that's West Palm Beach it's
kind of like in a war you know in a war
when the Conqueror conquerors the
conquered he can either say all right
give me tribute payments I own you now
you're conquered give me tribute
payments or they can come up with some
silly fakakta kind of legal document
that says well actually in reparation
for the war you need to pay us x amount
but it's it's just a legal veneer to
cover what is just brutal basic politics
and that that's what's going on right
here so if if this decision is thrown
out which it certainly should be they'll
just do some other version of it because
none of this has anything to do with the
value of Mar-A-Lago or Trump's
businesses or the bank loans he got or
any of it it obviously only has to do
with the 2024 election it has to do with
the fact that they view this man as a
danger to their political project and so
if if this stuff doesn't hold up in
court they'll just kill him at a certain
point they're just gonna kill I mean
that is the end goal of all of this
that's what Alex Jones was saying too
not that well that means it's true I'm
just saying he he is exactly like a
plane crash or something yeah let me let
me rephrase it then you know they will
they will kill him I can't do it yours
is better than mine how are you guys I
don't I disagree I don't think so you
don't think I got a better Alex Jones
than Michael you think mine is I don't
think I don't think I don't think
Trump's life is in danger
so uh this this strategy changed a long
time ago a political assassination's
immortalize ideologies you end up with
their faces painted I mean look Kurt
Cobain dies and they paint his face all
over all these buildings in a bunch of
different cities yeah yeah so what they
do now is character assassination which
they do to Trump the problem is it
doesn't work it just doesn't work with
them but this is
I mean this is why I say Civil War
that's why I don't I don't I don't think
that this ends with them being like okay
we have to stop Trump by any means
necessary it starts with them saying the
system has broke there's no there's no
moving forward there's no high conflict
they definitely don't want to make them
a martyr but that's why they invented
the heart attack gun and stuff where it
doesn't look like an assassination like
he died in his hotel room
it doesn't matter well I don't want to
talk too much about it John F Kennedy
gets shot and immediately conspiracy
theories the CIA did it and now Ron Paul
comes on Tim Caster Island says it comes
on IRL saying the CIA did it it is now
basically mainstream RFK is saying that
you you can't your heart attack gun it's
not gonna work anything bad happens to
Trump instantly all Trump supporters
believe it was it was malicious
something something bad happened if the
aspartame and Big Macs haven't gotten
them already you know I don't buy a
heart attack okay no they're gonna
they're going for character and they're
destroying his net worth now yeah they
are they are trying to make him a
homeless person that's the only thing
they can do
if anything bad happens to Trump whether
it's an whether it's him being mugged or
is plane crashing or he just has a heart
attack from Big Max and and Diet Coke he
will be immortalized that's it's very
true man so they want to strip them of
their wealth you want them to Fade Into
Obscurity and be forgotten about you
want their children to have no no errors
no titles you don't want any of that
because that's just a headache in the
future so they're trying to take it all
away from him and his family exactly
especially digital banishment so what do
they do so one you've got the
prosecutions put them in prison
immobilize him basically strip him of
his resources strain him so he can't run
and can't be as influential they're
basically just attaching as many weights
as possible to drop so so they make him
ineffective
the next thing we just saw them do a
judge summarily ruled that means there's
no trial a judge just banged a gavel the
Trump organization is to be dissolved in
10 days yeah so what's that some random
judge just said yeah now do they be like
okay nah we're gonna do some real laws
yeah uh well they're filing an appeal
but what will happen because we are in
we are in civil Strife territory Civil
War territory this judge says it you
know for a fact New York Democrat
government is going to be like oh well
right canceled Trump organization
dissolved there's there's there's not
going to be some principled person in
the Democrat Trifecta New York State
going
well I mean this is a little crazy for
the judge to rule this I don't think no
they're going to be like okay hopefully
there's wealthy businessmen in the
Democratic party that are going to be
like this could happen to me if they can
just go bang bang and dissolve people
there's never a selfless thought like
that no there are a few you guys like do
we want to live in a world where Trump
has nothing left to lose isn't that a
little bit scary get on baby let's go
then what he has now and also since he's
been you know digitally banished like
you said Ian why is he still waiting to
come back to Twitter
platform he has left I mean he's not
really using it right but he did post
the mug shot that's why that's it though
but he's he's not saying enough he's
it's because whatever he posts on truth
is instantly reposted already yeah but
when he does post on X it's major
breaking news huge so he's he's using
that like like bike shot I do wonder if
if this goes through if this ridiculous
judge in Leticia James get their way uh
does it really matter I mean one will it
dissolve the Trump organization but two
it's not like Donald Trump makes
automobiles you know it's not like
Donald Trump makes widgets the company
is him it's just him it's his name it's
his face it's his lifestyle it's his
impromature on various other products so
can't he just start it again they can't
just be Trump organization too Electric
Boogaloo and you know this one's going
to be registered in Tennessee instead of
New York but I mean I think they're
seizing the properties I mean how is
this going to operate some of the pro
some of the companies that are being
dissolved are just holding companies
right so uh what so for people aren't
familiar when you're buying a property
you form an LLC which owns the company
but they're gonna they're gonna take his
actual properties but who if they're
dissolving the company then who retains
ownership of the property they've
dissolved The Entity that owns it yeah
fires I don't know can we start bidding
on it they're calling it the corporate
death penalty if the company owns the
property and the company gets dissolved
who owns the property
so it goes to auction at that point and
that's crazy if if you as a human being
Ian Crossland owned property and then
you're 80 years old and you pass on and
you have no next of kin or whatever who
gets the property well the state will
probably just take it I think that's
what happens if you die and there's no
one else or it goes here next of kin or
whatever a corporation doesn't have any
of that the corporation is gone where
does the property go I imagine it would
be the same as if somebody died I just
don't know I mean that's just so that is
like Fidel Castro level stuff and I
don't I I don't doubt that they want to
do it I just can't imagine the American
people put up with that I assume there
have got to be some reasonable Democrats
I know that's a bad assumption but
people who don't want the entire system
of business law to be totally upended in
the United States just because they hate
the mean orange man but maybe not maybe
they're irrational enough to do
something like that I I think you're
right you know it's just a matter of
people being aware of what the hell is
happening a lot of times too I just love
this is also another species of one of
the dumb anti-trump attacks which is you
know he's not really that rich I always
loved that in 2016. some guy who doesn't
have two pennies to rub together you
know Trump's actually he's broke like
well he flies around in a 747 for his
entire adult life so I if he's broke
he's doing a good job fooling all of us
he's living off my head he knows how to
work the system
and not pay it back if you know if
you're a good business it's not that he
doesn't he does pay it back you pay back
as little as possible just to keep the
banks happy and then you use it all that
loan that investment money to reinvest
to make more than the the interest that
you owe you have you have a billion
dollars cash in a a 999 million cash out
and then a million in your pocket every
month or something like that so it's a
massive rotation but I loved when they
were saying Donald Trump's a failed
businessman he's had five bankruptcies
or whatever and that was a success in
business if you can pull off a
successful bankruptcy yeah but it's not
that it's that bankruptcy doesn't mean
you've lost it's bankruptcy protection
to preserve the business secondly Trump
had over 500 businesses and only a small
handful uh that's bankruptcy then they
said whatever happened to Trump Stakes
or Trump magazine or Trump water see
where are those things and I was like
all of those things are at Trump's Golf
Resorts
go to Trump Doral and you will get a
bottle of trump water you will see a
trump mag you will be delivered a trump
stake to your room what they don't
understand is these companies Trump
started are just Trump supplying his own
product to cut costs for his Golf
Resorts vertical integration yeah right
McDonald's makes their own mayonnaise
yes exactly but also McDonald's brand
managed it's not in stores they failed I
mean he tried you know he tried the
Airlines and now he's just got his plane
but right but and they say see he failed
at that Airline I I've noticed that
every single successful person on planet
Earth
has failed a lot of times that is that
is one of the markers of success and
most of them have failed more than
anyone has even tried to succeed at
anything else so I just don't see how
that even that's enough well of the 5
000 things the man's ever done one of
them flops like okay that's pretty good
yeah not bad let's have a university
like his biggest flop Trump University
was probably the silliest flight yeah
But I it was it wasn't the biggest
property he had though and also I have a
PhD from there I heard it was a scandal
is it real what was the Scandal about
Trump well it's not like you know it's
it's not a school like um you know
Stanford or Harvard or something meaning
if you send your kid to Trump University
the kid won't end up trans you know or
hate you when they graduate
it's it's it's the whole accreditation
system in my opinion is meaningless it's
not accredited well I don't know if it
was I don't believe it was I think it
was just like a kind of scammy sounding
company but who you know there's like a
million of these things I think it was
more so that it just didn't get going
yeah Trump tried to start a thing out of
people in went nowhere and then it fell
apart and they were like yo what the you
know yeah but I mean does anyone really
think Trump University is more of a scam
than like half of the actually
accredited universities in America today
it's less of a scam you're right let's
uh let's jump to this story because last
night uh we had social breakdown in
Philadelphia Philly police arrest 52
people in connection with rioting and
looing so basically last night you had
absolute Insanity in Philadelphia over a
hundred people running around smashing
Windows breaking into into stores and
liquor stores just stealing whatever
they wanted and uh they didn't care they
didn't care about the police they didn't
care about what was going on and the
police can't stop it there was an
influencer named meatball yeah
livestream got arrested
um for stealing bread from an Apple
Store
bread bread yeah wait what just to you
know they're they're just trying to get
by yeah just trying to get food too
that's right keep surviving right
because that's what AOC said right that
they're just struggling to get by so
yeah you know they went in bad for
meatballs I was picturing just meatballs
and a nice juicy hoagie roll and I kind
of lost track of the story for a second
but yeah yeah do they feed their
families with Dior handbags I don't know
well I've never tried was when they
stole all the Apple products and went
outside the alarms on the dices went off
saying you're being tracked they smashed
them all yeah but this is this is my
point that I made earlier when I talk
about social breakdown
let me spell it out for you if police
are not held accountable when they
commit crimes then you get this
what do you think the political
equivalent of this would be so I'll give
so I'll give an example
uh I don't believe that all caps are bad
I think that's silly uh the the a cab
people are are nuts I think police are a
purpose but the problem is when we get
instances of police impropriety we are
not likely to get accountability I can
speak to an example when uh the example
I often give of when I filmed the police
wrongly arrest a photographer in New
York who then filed a false police
report and lied and additionally lied
under oath to try and convict a guy who
had done nothing wrong the police
claimed that he was standing in the
middle of the street blocking traffic
when he was on the sidewalk and I filmed
him on the sidewalk and they arrested
him cops lied they just didn't want a
photographer taking pictures of what
they were doing there was never any
accountability for those cops now
you get a piece of information like that
it's a problem how do we fix it I don't
know it's it's this there's got to be a
solution to it the leftists propaganda
is that amplify it and then lie about
other instances because this seed means
you get a George Floyd you get an Ahmed
Aubry no one will trust the police yeah
it doesn't matter if you're a fan of the
cops or not the point is this
the more stories you get and the more
videos you get of police and propriety
going unpunished you'll end up with
people like this saying the police have
no jurisdiction over me why would I
listen to the these gang members if and
this is what I've explained before if a
gang member subscribe and says I'm the
boss now do as I said you'd better get
out of here if a cop shows up now you're
like okay I gotta call my lawyer they
have a warrant now I gotta listen what's
happening now is police are being viewed
no different than another gang not think
about the political equivalent to this
if politicians in Congress can Insider
trade with no accountability we know
they're corrupt we know they're taking
these dirty deals we know they're
playing dirty games in politics we now
know that Democrats are going after
Trump supporters they're going after the
president himself they're solving his
businesses what's the political
equivalent
you're going to get factions of in
combination with this and the politics
what you will see is regular guys in
their neighborhoods starting
neighborhood watches yeah they're going
to say the police won't stop the crime
the police can't be held accountable the
government is going to arrest us we have
to protect ourselves what happens when
you get 56 different factions all
throughout the United States in their
small town areas asserting their
jurisdiction outside of the county the
state or the federal government
a Birth of a Nation yeah it's look it's
the way you're describing it is to the
extreme extent but at the smaller level
you know when people are just starting
these Community watches and they're
maybe just arming themselves and they're
just making sure that if you exercise
your second amendment rights that people
are going to be more polite around you
that's all good stuff you know it I
don't want to sound like I'm just trying
to make lemonade out of lemons here and
and I'd like to avoid Civil War if if we
can do that but if if people have a
little bit more situational awareness
now and people don't spend their time
hanging around downtown Philly because
it's going up in flames and people start
exercising their rights and and working
with their neighbors to say Hey you know
we're not gonna we're gonna make sure
this is a small town try that in a small
town man yeah I mean look these guys
could be could be canceled right but
like I don't know I like a little
accountability so so here's what I
imagine
these people are smashing businesses and
Flash mobbing all over the place it's
been happening non-stop for several
years now and it's getting worse this is
the worst we've seen not only are they
targeting stores now you have 100 people
running through the shopping district
and smashing up a bunch of stores
and the police are only able to stop
around half
you're gonna get people who say try that
in a small town try that in a small town
what's the implication there the
implication is that we in a small town
will defend ourselves we will shoot you
that is so it's the subtext and here's
what happens there will be people in a
neighborhood in a suburb in a blue state
that will have guns the police will show
up and say we are coming to take your
guns away and those people are going to
be like f you no you're not because you
don't protect us from the flash mobs and
the roving gangs that are shooting at us
and killing people and the plays are
going to say shut your mouth and get on
your knees
welcome to a modern Lexington and
Concord I don't think that that'll it'll
come to that though it seems like maybe
maybe because we got the internet maybe
because we're American we've got this
culture that the cops are kind of like
pissed off at this like local cops don't
want to go harass people and take their
weapons they don't want us to create
that kind of animosity I don't agree I
think if a cop gets in order to go take
some guy's gun they're gonna be like no
no you do it dude I'm not gonna step in
front of that guy's okay Second
Amendment I got one I got one for you
Ian if uh the police were ordered to
arrest local local uh community members
in their own City because foreign
Nationals had entered do you think the
cops would be like I'm not going to
arrest the guy who lives here because
you want me to protect a foreign citizen
do you think they do it I don't know
they did it already the police in Staten
Island arrested the local residents who
were protesting their government
shipping in non-citizens and paying them
the police arrested the people who live
there how about the guy was in his own
home when BLM showed up protesting and
the man in his own home knowing these
guys had set fire to another house
recently brandished a weapon the cops
went into his house and arrested him
you know you know the sad part of all of
this I mean that's all pretty sad
I think people will just probably go
along with it I I like to think they're
going to say no I'm going to stand up
for my rights and my way of life and but
man if even Staten Island can be pushed
around those are like the most obnoxious
you know sort of stubborn people we
talked about this last night the
American Revolution took 20 years it
started in 1764 and it went until 1783.
the the revolution started one year and
a month before the signing of the
Declaration of Independence and the
Battle of Lexington Lexington and
Concord which wasn't really a battle it
was a bunch of farmers shooting at
effectively police the reason why that
marked the start the shot heard around
the world was because before this
everyone said exactly what you were just
saying right now no one's going to stand
up for themselves no one's ever going to
get into conflict with the regulars no
one will stand against the crown until
one day when the crown said we're coming
to take your guns and they went to the
militias in the rural parts of
Massachusetts and they said over our
cold dead hands someone started shooting
we don't know who I I think it's fair to
assume it was the Americans who opened
fire on on the crown first I think some
drunk militia man like like yeah I don't
think that was it at all I think 300
regulars marching down the street
pointing muskets at you and one guy
somebody did not trigger we're just like
I'm done with it this is my fear but the
problem is I don't see an offering as
Phil Labonte describes it because all we
ask for is like guys it's really simple
police you can't arrest a local resident
because they're upset you shipped in
non-citizens to their neighborhood and
are giving them their tax dollars let me
make this clear for everybody
non-citizen illegally enters the country
gets a free bus ride or plane ride to
your hometown to Staten Island to where
you live
your tax dollars to New York City are
now paying these non-citizens who also
have police protections from you and
special protected status that AOC has
fought for
they're working underground jobs and
they're not paying taxes yo I'm sorry
man I'm I'm deeply concerned about
things like that I'm deeply concerned
about the fact that Colorado has no
abortion restrictions and Oklahoma has
total abortion restrictions hyper
polarization but but most importantly
the immigration thing I think is the
scariest thing yeah but but think about
how effective it's been you know we're
we're paying attention to it now in
particular because you see the crazy
stuff in Staten Island where you see
lampedusa gets overrun with more
migrants than citizens of this of the
island but this has been going on now
for over about 65 years the movement of
people into the United States over the
last 65 years is the largest movement of
people ever in recorded history so you
know the hour is a bit late on this
issue and there's this bizarre fact that
no matter which party you elect you just
get more more migration the the hour is
a bit late but all that means to me is
that it'll be worse than it should have
been if 50 years ago or whenever it
started people just said hey hey we're
stopping this right now now there's no
conflict you just sign the paperwork and
things are done maybe a little heated
arguments in Congress but now we're
talking about million a million plus
people per year now we're at the point
where the people who hey look man all
that is required for evil to Triumph is
good men do nothing good people do
nothing right and so the people of
Staten Island but mostly men I think we
know right sure but but the people of
Staten Island did nothing these are
people who who pay taxes and support a
machine and say leave me out of it I
don't care about politics I don't think
about that stuff that's the one
Republican Borough there you go and then
one day they wake up
and there's a bus being shipped in of
non-citizens and they're saying hey your
tax dollars everyone's got a pitch in
for these guys and they're like wait
these 20 year old men from El Salvador
and well sorry not El Salvador
Salvador's doing really well everyone's
moving back but from Guatemala no
seriously though but from Honduras and
Guatemala who are fleeing here then when
they come out and they say hey get this
bus out of here the cop looks them
straight in the eyes with a joker grin
and says I will crack you over the skull
if you stop what we are doing to your
home and then what happens the cops beat
and arrest the people who live there to
protect the non-citizens yeah this is
unsustainable you know it's it's insane
I guess though that's my point is that
even the the Republican Borough with the
tough Italian Staten Islanders most
people haven't even heard this story
nothing really happened and so look
maybe something right right but
this is you're saying just wait and
it'll well so if the the revolutionary
period started in 1764 and it took 11
years to get to the point where people
were opening opening fire on regulars
you know we could be eight years away or
if the four if the straws house
generational theory is correct then
we're looking at maybe four I think in
four years we're in deep trenches of
serious conflict in in our Urban in the
United States yeah what about the world
do you think I can't imagine that
something would happen the United States
and not the rest of the world like it
would be a global Firestorm or something
like that if the US destabilizes in this
way
China immediately takes Taiwan and and
try and take the western United States
it would be like land grab Central like
if the Civil War or the Revolutionary
War was a French opportunity to take
control of the the Atlantic Ocean by
demolishing the British and they did
that so when you make a good point to
Ian which is you've already got this
this difficult situation we're in where
the the West led by America is decaying
and China is largely On The Rise so
you're seeing what people are calling
the inevitability of a bipolar World
already so cracking us hegemony for the
first time since the Cold War is Over
and frankly even a little earlier than
that so when you when you have a shift
in the world order to that degree it
almost always ends in war in a world war
so is it possible that just as we're on
the brink of our civil war and you know
pulling out our muskets to shoot our
cousins uh that we find ourselves in a
global conflict already where the stakes
are even higher yep does Russia Advance
knowing that the United States is
completely destabilized and if Russia
does do a larger push say with nuclear
artillery and I use that as an example
because I'm sure they have other weapons
and other techniques that could be
divisive and Powerful but a nuclear
weapon creates a hyperpolarization in
the United States one side the left
saying this is our Cassis belly we must
stop Vladimir Putin and the right would
say this is your fault we should not
have been in Ukraine in the first place
you caused this we need to extract and
and and remove ourselves now
and then what happens do you think after
a nuclear artillery is dropped in
Ukraine that there's I mean this this
would extreme political instability
already in this country
they're not going to have the public
support to Warrant sending more troops
more dollars more more resources to
Ukraine we now know thanks to CBS
surprisingly that the US is not only
funding the war we're funding the small
businesses of Ukraine right when the
federal government shuts down
Ukraine will still the U.S will be
paying the salaries of Ukrainian
citizens while not paying veterans
benefits now I do think netgate said
they did get a measure through a single
subject spending Bill to guarantee
veterans benefits they're duking it out
right now I mean as we're speaking
they're on the floor of the house right
now duking this out but but I the thing
I love about this government shutdown
look we now shut down the government
every year so I don't even pay attention
to it really this is just this year's
shutdown and the thing I love about it
is that it's going to show you who
really runs your government because just
as you say we're going to shut down all
non-essential services but those
paychecks to the shop owner in Ukraine
they're going to keep going it doesn't
matter what the people in Congress say I
I think from for most I think most
people in this country don't care
you tell them that tax dollars are going
to Ukraine they're going to be like I I
can't see it right I'll tell you
something funny
in uh you ever play poker you play
protection so you're familiar with table
rank versus time rake
no okay go to a casino and most of them
do what's called a table rake where that
that's every every every hand everyone
gets dealt two cards everybody puts
money in and then you can increase the
wager and if you can't if you don't want
to pay it you full
the casinos typically take five to seven
dollars out of the pot as what's called
a table rate so every hand that's dealt
they will pull ten percent up to six
dollars and put it in their bin that
means if they're doing 20 to 30 hands
per hour times six dollars
some some card clubs do what's called a
table rake which is I'm sorry A Time
rake every half an hour everyone pays
seven dollars
if you do what's what's called time rake
you physically pick the money up and
hand it to the to the dealer and you're
like that sucked if you do a table rake
you never know because the dealer is
pushing you your winnings and pulling
from it without you realizing and people
beg for table rake which take
substantially more money away from them
the reason I bring this up is when it
comes to us funding Ukraine so long as
the American people can't see the money
extract from their accounts they won't
care right as soon as if if it was if if
Joe Biden said everyone's gonna we're
gonna debit your bank account five
dollars to fund the war in Ukraine there
would be a riot it'd be over in one
second but you know what they're really
gonna do is it's all funny money and
we're so incredibly in debt at this
point that people don't even pay
attention to it and well even even if
the Congress doesn't approve more
Appropriations for Ukraine which is
possible what's going to happen is
they're going to just discover another
six billion dollars the part of remember
this was a few months ago they
discovered six billion dollars they
meant to send to Ukraine and that that
wasn't really true that's not really
what happened what really happened is
the political Powers who were running
our war in Ukraine are side of the war
in Ukraine they decided that Ukraine
needed some more stuff so they
retroactively changed the price of the
weapons that we sent over and said no
actually look we appropriated this
amount of money and it turns out those
weapons they were cheaper than we
thought we just yeah we figured it out
though and anyway so we're gonna send it
more but it's okay we're not spending
any more money because we just uh
retroactively change the prices okay
great
it's it's it's going to be interesting
to see how people respond to the fact
that our government shuts down and we
keep paying ukrainians it's like well
your government won't pay you government
employee but the ukrainians get their
paycheck have a nice day frankly I'd
rather pay the ukrainians than the IRS
I mean I agree I need help whatever you
care I got nothing against the
ukrainians I have a lot against the IRS
yeah I I think that if we cut it's like
here's the deal you know actually you
know what I I will I will completely
agree with funding Ukrainian small
business and their First Responders
that's as far as I go I don't care for
the war stuff they're First Responders
saving lives they're small businesses
but the money needs to come from the IRS
the ATF the FBI the CIA and the NSA FDA
too because they have two of my cigars
get rid of them too yeah yeah none of
that so you shut down the FBI and use
the money to fund the war in Ukraine
that way please everyone you please
everyone okay hear that Vivek uh yeah
compromise for all the viewers would you
agree with those terms we will abolish
the ATF FBI and CIA but we do have to
use the money that would have gone to
those branches to and send it to Ukraine
that's a good poll do you guys um and I
you can't speak for daily wires but I
kind of ask you just in general the talk
around the office and stuff we talk a
lot about the solutions to the political
is like in the private sector is that
where your head's at that's my some of
my colleagues think that they're they're
much more into you know doing things
through the private sector and uh
culture I want to use the heavy hand of
the law baby I've you know look there's
a role for both of these things but I
just fear sometimes when conservatives
Focus exclusively on politics being
Downstream of culture we forget that
that the law is also a teacher and I
think sometimes what politicians do is
they use that phrase which is true
enough in itself politics is Downstream
of culture they use that as an excuse
not to do anything and not to pass any
laws not to wield any power and not to
they just say oh no we need to make
better movies or whatever yeah no no the
movie makers are better movies you're in
Congress you need to use your political
power man well the debate's starting you
guys ready oh yes do it here we go I
can't wait
bergamentum oh you're all about burger
oh I'm a big burgum guy yeah he's great
and I am thrilled shout out to rumble
moderators Fox News Channel Dana Perino
and Ilya Calderon
wow a very exotic panel fix your
audience
thank you thank you
Reagan famously describe America as a
shining city on a hill and tonight seven
candidates will make the case they
should be hanging the one what are they
doing into a brighter tomorrow but first
they have to convince you
they're not going to I'm voting for
Trump
please allow me to welcome
audience
what the what the hell is this so why
are we speaking a foreign language and
an American presidential tonight
Spanish in Florida tonight they are
positioned by The order they rank in the
polls with the highest polling candidate
in the middle it's not the Santa stage
Florida Governor it's Ron DeSanto I
guess technically pain in his eyes
[Applause]
wow a bunch of polls show I had to have
had to have match-ups with Biden Nikki
Haley is winning by uh Sanders is losing
I believe it I believe that people
underestimate Nikki and she's moderate
so conservative yeah
she is but I don't like she's too
Warhawk you're not gonna you're not
gonna vote for it right
there he is the Dark Horse
candidates get one minute to answer and
30 seconds to respond it's singled out
when their time runs out we'll all hear
this
yeah that means nothing we have a lot of
ground to cover please
dude this audio is awful let's get going
yeah it's a hanger
spacious Sunny
to reflect the very nature and character
of Ronald Reagan it's a place that makes
you proud to be an American
yet today our nation is drowning in
division and incivility
voters say they dread the 2024 election
and find politics exhausting two in
three Americans think the country is on
the wrong track and three in four say
they the economy is not in good shape
prices are up 18 since 2020. more than
half of the U.S population has little
access to child care 85 percent of
Americans say their personal finances
are a source of stress
Americans want to believe a leader who
says you can follow me I've got you a
lot of wind up for this I know yeah he's
trying to do that I'm like rolling my
eyes economics and yesterday he joined
the picket lines where Auto Workers are
demanding more wages
I like that lady's accent praising yeah
no I like all of them including the
controllers
yeah as it's meant to be spoken erotic
and thousands of striking Auto Workers
today Senator obviously the president
United States cannot fire anybody in the
private sector however we should look
back at the first Bill in Congress under
Pro Joe Biden the first Bill had 86
billion dollars for the union pensions
because they continue to over promise
yet under deliver one of the challenges
that we have in the current negotiations
is that they want four-day French work
weeks but more money they want more
benefits working fewer hours that is
simply not going to stand I said in a
finance committee hearing when a widow
came before the committee whose promised
pensions from from the unions four
thousand dollars a month unfortunately
it had been cut to a thousand dollars a
month we must make sure that we honor
the commitments that we make and one of
the ways that we do that do not over
promise and then under deliver and leave
the taxpayers on the hook I'll say this
Joe Biden should not be on the picket
line he should be on the southern border
working to close yeah there we go
Southern border because it is unsafe it
was too wonky an intro to that answer
but
he realized he was losing it
was 12 months because
didn't know it all it devastating every
County in America is now a border County
because fentanyl has devastated
Americans in every single state I will
also say six million illegal Crossings
because he started out answering the
question which was a very dumb idea
nobody cares about the Auto Workers
finish the wall
reinstate title 42 and get the job done
get it done
[Applause]
for sure Spirit of it I'll say that I
don't have a lot of patience for the
union bosses I think that's where he and
I actually have a common view I do have
a lot of Sympathy for the workers
however people are going through real
hardship in this country I've been
through hardship growing up my father
stared down layoffs said GE under Jack
Welch's tenure at the GE plant in
Evendale Ohio my mom had to work
overtime in nursing homes in Southwest
Ohio to make ends meet and pay off our
home loan so I understand that hardship
is not a choice
but victimhood is a choice and we choose
to be victorious in the United States of
America you know what if I was given
advice to those workers I would say go
pick it in front of the White House in
Washington D.C that's really where the
protest needs to be disastrous economic
policies that have driven up prices that
have driven up interest rates in
mortgage rates at the same time wages
remaining stagnant what we need is to
deliver economic growth in this country
unlock American energy drill Frac burn
coal Embrace nuclear energy put people
back to work by no longer paying them
more money to stay at home stabilize the
U.S dollar itself and rescind a majority
of those unconstitutional federal
regulations that are hampering our
economy that is how we unleash American
exceptionalism and that's not a
democratic Vision or a republican Vision
that is an American Vision that we
Embrace economic growth and capitalism
is still the best system known to man to
lift us up from poverty and we should
not apologize for it that's what it
means to be an American he's too smart
yeah yeah he's a smart guy man he yeah
he needed a more the CEOs he needed an
answer that was more like okay it's a
simple sweet treats
that he's just a silver spoon it's just
pot I like what he said I grew up had
some hardship usually I find it cheesy
but it's helpful because no one knows
who the fake is right I thought it was
is that actually true though yeah who
knows I've been friends with him for a
while but I don't know if his parents
were immigrants but you also support how
these companies operate which is it
well thank you for the question I want
to thank Univision and Fox Business for
assembling such a wonderful forum
look I do disagree with something Tim
Scott just said Joe Biden doesn't belong
on a picket line he belongs on the
unemployment line
I mean look nobody cared in the country
he paused for clap but nobody gave it to
him yeah that was we brought 12 000
factories back to America during our
Administration I know something about
Manufacturing and I got to tell you what
uh while the union bosses are talking
about class Warfare and talking about
disparity in wages I have to tell you I
really believe what's driving that is
bidenomics has failed wages are not
keeping up with inflation Auto Workers
and All American workers are feeling it
and families are struggling in this
economy and Joe Biden's Green New Deal
agenda is good for Beijing and bad for
Detroit we ought to repeal the green New
Deal get rid of the mandates and
subsidies that are driving American
gasoline Automotive manufacturing into
the graveyard and beyond that also as
president of the United States I'll be
standing with workers all across America
and I'll be standing for the right to
work of every American to join a union
or not join a union as they decide
when you catching response I said
sleeping for that Joe Biden needs to be
fired that's why I'm running for
president I look forward to being the
next president of the United States I
will also say I know America can do
foreign
I go back to college he was at the law
school when I was an undergraduate and
we we didn't really know each other in
college but we were in similar circles
and groups and uh
and then we reconnected because he
started making waves in politics and
then five seconds later he was running
for president and I thought well that's
crazy and then five seconds later he was
pretty good at it you know he's like
number two or three he was a Libertarian
at College were you also libertarian I
hate to confess my sins in public but I
was a bit he said he was like pretty
libertarian but then he found the
inaction or just the the action of the
Republican Party aligned more with his
his
appetite for politics yeah and he but he
also you know he wasn't out doing
political activism or anything in in
school when he was at the law school he
was preparing this company that made him
about a bazillion dollars
distortions like the state I just
reloaded that they give to wealthy
people in in blue States and not in paid
by Red States and let's make sure we
make the small business taxes permanent
they only made those temporary they made
the corporate taxes permanent let's
focus on what it takes to get more cash
in the pockets of workers that's when
we'll be able to deal with strikes like
this not sitting on a picket line like
Joe Biden is thank you Governor Haley we
have other questions together
when their answers are like let's fix
the problem and offer a solution you're
like yeah what put money in their hands
like what I'm sorry I know they only
have 30 seconds I have to jump in
because we're missing the point and
every other network is missing the point
the reason why people are striking in
Detroit is because Joe Biden's
interference with capital markets and
with free markets yes subsidies we're
subsidizing the automakers and we're
subsidizing the cars in a particular
kind of car not every car we're
particularly we're subsidizing electric
vehicles and when you decide that we're
going to take it
take a billion dollars subsidize a
certain type of vehicle and the
batteries come from China China controls
85 percent of the rare earth minerals
they're called Rare Earth because I
think I'm becoming an unironic version
so that we can make and make a battery
that's in a car subsidized here that's
why they're striking because they need
the most substance part of any of this
today Joe Biden this strike is a Joe
Biden's feet
I really like that yeah
wow
Governor Christie the government will
shut down if Congress does not reach a
deal by the end of this week
vice president Pence warns that politics
of quote Trump's populists prodigies
like Mr ramaswamy are a road to ruin for
the GOP if the government shuts down
should voters blame populist Republicans
unfortunately everybody who's in
Washington DC they get sent down there
to do the job and they've been failing
it doing the job for a very long time
and let's be honest about this with the
voters you know during the Trump
Administration they added seven trillion
dollars
seven trillion dollars in national debt
and now the Biden Administration has put
another 5 trillion on and Counting they
have failed and they're in the spot
they're in now because none of them are
willing to tell the truth none of them
are willing to take on the difficult
issues they just want to keep kicking
the can down the road and the inflation
that Nikki spoke about is absolutely
right and it's caused by government
spending and that's why people all
across this country are suffering
tonight and yet we don't get any answers
because Joe Biden hides in his basement
and won't answer as to why he's raising
the debt the way he's done and Donald
Trump be hides behind the walls of his
golf clubs and won't show up here to
answer questions like all the rest of us
are up here to answer this is low energy
he should be in this
DC who has failed to do their job and
just plays to the grandstand
I would rather be eating a Pizza Hut
pizza than watching reruns of The
Simpsons then listen to Chris Christie
yeah I would rather do that than most
things
people in Washington are shutting down
the American dream with their Reckless
Behavior they borrowed they printed they
spent and now you're paying more for
everything they are the reason for that
they have shut down our national
sovereignty by allowing our border to be
wide open so please spare me to the
crocodile tears for these people they
need to change what's going on and
where's Joe Biden he's completely
missing in action from leadership and
you know who else is missing in action
vetoed waste spending when it came
Ruskin is your president when they send
me a bloating bill that's going to cause
your prices to go I'm going to take out
this veto pen and I'm gonna send it
right back to them that was a really
good answer Ron I really appreciate it
yeah
don't you agree though he's got it going
at some point he's got to go Trump right
like it's not gonna it's almost
certainly not gonna work but they're
talking
some families are spending up to half of
their income yes on child care and
they're having to decide is it worth it
for me to work or does it not make sense
for me financially in three days the
billions of dollars in pandemic era
funding is going to end and 70 000 day
cares could close so you had an effort
to broaden eligibility for child care
assistance that fell apart last year
and for the moms and dads out there who
are worried
what can you tell them if you weren't
able to get it through the Congress how
could you do it as president so one of
the things I did as a member of Congress
was to make sure that we protected the
Head Start programs around the country
giving people the opportunity to pick
and choose the place that they send
their children the challenges that we
see today
every time it's it's him yeah
has gone over 15
000 per child in the build back broker
plan he called it a buildback better
plan it was going up to 29
000 the way we fixed that problem
Americans their money back
we actually launched a Single mother's
taxes by 70 on the federal level for
dual income households by 60 then we
went a step further we doubled the child
tax credit and made it refundable by
doing that more parents had more
resources to make the decisions how to
take care of their family the one thing
we should do is let the American people
keep their money when that happens the
greatest opportunities Rise From the
Ashes I heard that he enjoys the company
between the majority of us in this
country who love the United States of
America and share it's crazy how he
looks like he's 19. free speech he's 20
and a half get ahead in this country
of your character and The Fringe
minority in the Democrat Party that has
a choke hold over that party that's the
real divide so this populism
we need to unite this party
damn I thought they were they said
yeah he was doing really well before the
first debate now he's I think it's like
all these questions
young people loved it but older people
hated it so I felt it helped him but
there was going to be
it's too much for them
foreign
back uh very they may have entered
illegally
two years later President Reagan granted
amnesty to nearly 3 million immigrants
something no Democrat or Republican
president has done since Governor
Christie as governor of a non-border
state in 2010 you supported a path to
citizenship but when you run for
president in 2016 you flipped saying
immigrants should be tracked lymphatics
packages
[Applause]
the citizenship for 11 million of
undocumented immigrants well the problem
is that since no one has done anything
since we first had this discussion 13
years ago we're not in a position to be
able to do any of that anymore
what we have to do now is first treat
this like the law enforcement problem it
is our laws are being broken every day
at the southern border every day and Joe
Biden and his crew is doing nothing
about enforcing that law they are
letting it go and by the way they
announced during the presidential race
they were going to let it go and we need
to have a go a president who acts like I
did as Governor enforce the law first
and foremost and that means what I'll do
on day one is sign an executive order to
send the National Guard to partner with
Customs and Border Patrol to make sure
that we stop the flow of fentanyl over
the Border but also to make sure that we
send a much different message
we want you here in this country to fill
the Six Million vacant jobs we have but
only if you come here to follow the law
and only if you come here legally the
majority of Americans want to
drastically reduce and we will send you
back across the border from which you
came and the fact is that until we set a
Law and Order agenda in this country not
only now but in the future we won't we
won't be able to continue this and I'll
look I'll tell you this Donald Trump
failed on this as well he said he was
going to build a wall across the whole
border he built 52 miles of wall and
said Mexico would pay for it guess what
I think if Mexico knew that he was only
going to build 52 miles they might have
paid for the 52 miles
tip your waitress mostly illegal
immigrants what's your answer to the
immigration problems
less immigration more deportation that's
my tonight next question yeah just like
there you go in the last decade the U.S
has spent nearly 55 billion dollars to
address the root causes of migration but
crime poverty and Corruption women
persist and the number of migrants is
only growing are we wasting our money
premeditated criminals when Joe Biden
waved the green flag it told everybody
to come and now we've seen six million
people cross the border we've had more
fentanyl that have killed Americans in
the Iraq Vietnam or Afghanistan Wars
combined we need to make sure that we
are a country of laws the second we stop
being a country of laws we give up
everything this country was founded on
so we have to secure the border the way
we do that is first of all defund
Sanctuary cities you see what's
happening in Philadelphia right now it's
got to stop we need to make sure we put
25 000 more border patrol and Ice agents
on the ground and let them do their job
I spent 400 miles down that border
that's their jobs
instead of Catch and Release let's go to
catch and Deport what about
the aid that Federal taxpayers are
paying to deal with the root causes it's
not working these are the only Aid that
we should be spending right now is to
secure the border the southern border
the northern
only when we get the border secure
should we ever look at putting any more
money into this our money should be
about keeping Americans safe we're not
doing that Joe Biden's not doing that
and you mentioned Congress and and
shutting down government I'll make it
clear we have to change the budget
process in four years it in 40 years
Congress has only delivered a budget on
time for
well that was fun all right times in 40
years if they don't keep the government
open they should not get paid no pay no
budget that's the way
yes but she's still in the world side
effects Governor DeSantis China invested
12 billion dollars in Latin America just
last year they signed strategic
Partnerships with seven countries
including Mexico and China's military
ties to the region now include arms
sales and training exercises are you
comfortable with China deepening ties
with our Southern neighbors of course
not and the reason why we're in this
mess is because Elites in DC for far too
long have chosen surrender over strength
when it comes to the CCP some people in
our country got rich our industrial base
got hollowed out and they have been able
to build the second most powerful
military in the entire world we need a
totally new approach to China we are
going to have real hard power in the
indo-pacific like Reagan to deter their
Ambitions we're going to have economic
independence from China where we're
decoupling our economy and we are going
to go after the cultural power they have
in this country as governor of Florida I
banned the CCP from buying land in our
state we should do that all across these
United States we shouldn't have them in
our universities so
so if you see a country in Decline our
powers in Decline China is going to
surpass us this decade and if they do
that that's going to affect every single
American household as your president I
am not going to let that happen I'm
going to reverse this country's decline
we are going to choose strength not
surrender when it comes to the CCP
close quote Universal deportation
and their children
under what legal premise would you expel
U.S citizens so the first thing I want
to say is I agree with everything the
Republicans on the stage are on the
right side of this issue militarize the
southern border stop funding Sanctuary
cities and end foreign aid to Mexico and
Central America to end the incentives to
come across but I do go a step further
you're right about that Ilya I favor
ending Birthright citizenship foreign
between me and them is I've actually
read the 14th Amendment what it says is
that all persons born or naturalized in
the United States and subject subject to
the laws
we are citizens so nobody believes that
the kid of a Mexican Diplomat in this
country enjoys Birthright citizenship
not a judge or legal scholar in this
country will disagree with me on that
well if the kid of a Mexican Diplomat
doesn't enjoy Birthright citizenship
then neither does the kid of an illegal
migrant who broke the law to come here
and is the father of Tucson it is hard
for me to look them in the eye and say
you have to follow the law when our own
goodness
its own laws
and solve this there's some evidence
in the United States of America because
that is part of what it even means to be
an American
ending Birthright citizenship what you
were saying comment there's some issues
with common law so it is
our decision in 1898 but it goes back
further into the English common law
centuries and centuries
region you know into in under one's
Reign then you're the subject so it's a
tough legal argument to me or I think is
pertains to the 14th I think he's right
frankly if you come here illegally you
are not the surviving a supreme court
argument is something I can't tell you
but from a perspective of the
Constitution I think it's simple that
clearly it was designed for slavery and
not for illegal immigrants go one step
further though
we think about the fact that they just
said we were all good people and I
appreciate that because last debate he
said we were all bought and paid for and
I thought about that for a little while
and said you know I can't imagine how
you can say that knowing that you were
just in business with the Chinese
Communist Party
the same people that funded
Hunter Biden millions of dollars was a
partner of yours as well
Tim pulling out the shiv I want to
respond these are good people who are
tainted by a broken system and it's not
the fault of anybody
thank you for speaking while I'm
interrupting
thank you for speaking
okay you can't be on both sides
gentlemen you'll have your turn one of
the challenges
just talking till everyone else shuts up
I only want to hear from you
when every other CEO expanded into the
Chinese market you know what I did with
my first company we opened a subsidiary
in China but you know what I did that
was different than every other company
we got the hell out of there and when I
started my next company
really when I started my next company
strive to compete against excuse me
I made a commitment that we would never
do business in China and I will say
something if you think you have more
than time to explain I was interrupted
by a lot of people here and I want to be
respectful because I believe
but I do not believe it we're sitting
here in the Reagan Library yes I wish
McDonald's
slowly turn it down
until get control right yeah
vice president pence in 2017 the trumpet
the legal status of 600 000 dreamers in
the history
what channel is The Simpsons on
specifically Pizza Hut Supreme Court
with Congress to reach a permanent
solution for dreamers
first let me say I'm glad I'm glad Vivek
pulled out of his business deal in 2018
in China that must have been about the
time you decided to start voting in
presidential elections
I negotiated the remain in Mexico policy
with the with the Mexican Government
we used economic power to bring the
Mexican Government to the table we build
hundreds of miles of border wall
and despite what's said here today we
reduced illegal immigration and Asylum
abuse by 90 percent and as president of
the United States I can do it again
and the truth is the truth is we need to
fix a broken immigration system and I'll
do that as well but first and foremost a
nation Without Borders is not a nation
and we have to secure the southern
border of the United States of America I
know how to do it and we will do it
again let me say one other thing about
China
let me say one other thing about China
negotiate to
give a solution to the problem that
dreamers have right now they are on a
limbo let me tell you I served in
Congress for 12 years although it seemed
longer but you know something I've the
big singer was good but these other ones
because I've actually I've actually
secured reform in Congress you know you
know Ron you talk a really good game
about cutting spending but you've
increased spending in Florida by 30
percent when I was a member of Congress
in 2006 right after Hurricane Katrina
Dana you remember it we stood our ground
I led house conservatives we cut a
hundred billion dollars out of the
federal budget you know this is the old
can be done right I'll say again
is that he just brutally wields the
government against our enemies I don't
really care if he raises the military
times and we're going to get spending in
Washington DC under control once and for
all right
[Music]
the king's disease oh so they're gonna
go take a break and well I just trust
our government and where the economy is
[Laughter]
all right
well when the commercials are over we'll
come back my some takeaways Chris
Christie it sounds like he's struggling
to breathe which makes it hard to listen
to him unfortunately Pence does too bro
he doesn't sound like he's struggling
photography he doesn't sound like it he
is struggling and if he was nicer like
more friendly I think I'd really like
him Chris Christie I'm sorry he's such a
jerk no one should vote for for Chris
Christie yeah no one you know why it is
you know why yeah because he's fat and
sick
a big part of it if you can't take care
of yourself how do you take care of this
country true true and and and to be fair
the only the only pass Donald Trump gets
is not based on his health not based on
his diet it's based on the fact that
he's the closest person to firing people
who need to be fired that's it because
otherwise I'd agree and be like I mean
actually Trump did lose a lot of weight
surprised
felt 215 yeah
I read that you're talking about but
what about uh Taft it was a great
president yeah the biggest fattest guy
ever in the history of the world really
it's different when you get fat off of
like what people ate back then you know
that's true raw milk and bacon and pies
yes like a prime rib for breakfast I
think you're right because I shouldn't
be too hard on Chris Christie's weight
because I think he might actually be a
guest in the future and like a serious
like he's gonna be like Ian I heard what
you said about him
[Laughter]
I have a glandular problem
in politics I'm finding these people
that I think I hate and just from
through the media I end up meeting them
in person I really like them yeah well
that's that's a lesson I I I've talked
about before when I was a teenager and I
watched the skate video and me and my
friends were all just smack talking
these skaters about how cool we thought
we were and how they were losers with
their goofy clothes and then we go to
California end up meeting them and they
were super nice to us and like gave us
free food and gear and they're like you
guys rock man I was like I feel really
bad for talking bad about that for no
reason the culture war in a nutshell
yeah all this politicians are just as
bad as we think they are yeah or worse
but the ones that come in here I like
Sean Spicer for instance I love him like
I I have such a horrible view of him
through the media and then I was like
well I'm gonna meet Sean Spicer Steve
Bannon was another one I was like I'm
gonna I'm supposed to be afraid of this
guy I guess then I meet him and I'm like
oh these guys are legit like yeah I'm
just smart straightforward then you see
like AOC who is as bad she tells her
constituents who are yelling at her no
more illegal immigrants she screams over
them we're gonna give them your tax
dollars we're gonna give them your homes
and we're gonna give them special
protected status I'm sorry that's evil
yeah no no some some are bad but I I'm
with you once you meet a lot of
politicians you realize that many of
them are kind of boring and uh some of
them are it's not that they're evil
they're just like they don't care that
much about much of anything but a lot of
them actually are like nice good people
who were like a little bit nerdy in
school and you know they're just yeah
it's kind of sad because if they were
truly just menacing evil monsters it
would explain why the country is so
degraded but like a lot of them are just
kind of you know showing up and doing
their job yeah getting a job on the
bridge of the Death Star and like why
does everyone hate me no here's the
question how many members of Congress
can you name let's how many members of
the house I don't know 20
we've probably interviewed more than 20
members of Congress I can't name any of
them yeah you know we know the ones we
like we know the ones we don't like and
then I have had full conversations with
members of Congress
not recognizing them at all yeah and I I
work in politics for a living you know
and I just a lot of them you just don't
even prominent ones yeah yeah all right
looks like we're back
oh that's a cool venue it's Reagan's uh
library library for the second
Republican presidential debate I do want
to just remind you there's one minute
for questions
so we want to talk about crime this has
been um
Philadelphia we should have just winged
you said in the last time
local prosecutors won't but next time
the shoplifting all the carjackings the
armed robberies they're all surging
Progressive prosecutors were elected by
their constituents and they can't be
fired by a president so what would you
do to end the Republicans
the only one on this stage who's done it
no for seven years I ran the fifth
largest office in this country at the
U.S attorney's office in New Jersey and
we set records for the number of
prosecutions that we brought that still
have not been broken and the reason was
that we went after the crime that was
affecting people's lives as president I
will appoint an attorney general and
instruct that attorney general that you
are to put all the resources that are
necessary to bring our cities back under
control the fact is they will be strong
there's no doubt about that and it's
what they take the job for because they
love the idea of enforcing the law we've
got the wrong order back to this country
and not just in our cities but we need
to Law and Order back everywhere
rural areas people feel threatened there
and we need it in Washington DC also and
Donald Trump should be here to answer
for that but he's not and I want to look
at account right now
yourself I know you're watching okay and
you're not here tonight not because of
polls
you're not here tonight because you're
afraid of being on the stage and
Defending Your record now I'm pretty
sure it's a polls actually that's pretty
sure pretty sure the reason he's not
there is because the police
a couple of the prosecutors in your
state but as Governor I mean you are a
good man you would not have the ability
to do that how do you think about
dealing with these real causes of crime
especially this revolving door of the
criminals they just get out and come
back and commit another crime well the
crime in these cities is is one of the
strongest signs of the decaying of
America we can't be successful as a
country if people aren't even safe to
live in places like Los Angeles and San
Francisco just being in Southern
California over the last couple days my
wife and I have met three people who
have been mugged on the street great and
that would have never happened 10 or 20
years ago in Florida we back the blue we
support the men and women of law
enforcement they are keeping us safe we
have a 50-year low in the crime rate and
yes when I had two stories
weren't following the law in Florida I
remember from their posts and the people
in Florida are saying
we'll use the justice department to
bring civil rights cases against all of
those left-wing Soros funded prosecutors
we're not going to let them get away
with it anymore reverse this country's
decline we need to choose Law and Order
over rioting and disorder and I will not
let you down
I would be like I will prosecute all of
the Democrats illegally gone after
Donald Trump
three years ago you signed a pledge to
support law enforcement now pledges are
a nice idea but what's your actual plan
to get more police on our streets
well and I actually did it in South
Carolina too you know what we knew in
South Carolina was you take care of
those who take care of you we have to
start taking care of law enforcement but
it's not just taking care of them with
words it's making sure that you also
follow through on what they do right now
we have a lot of stolen guns on the
street well these Law Enforcement
Officers they arrest these people and
then they go and they're let out the
very next day so law enforcement feels
like they don't no one has their back we
have to start Prosecuting according to
the law we have to make sure we have the
backs of law enforcement and we have to
make sure that we're a country of Law
and Order but I want to go back to China
because I don't think we spent enough
time on that now we have to look at what
government's doing to hurt us against
China too you have a company U.S
antibiotics that produces amoxicillin
the number one antibiotic that we need
and right now there is a company in
Bristol Tennessee that produces that yet
our federal government only gets it from
China we need to be focusing on
companies that produce in America and
supporting those companies that produce
in America
good point I expected it to be something
thank you um Stuart we're going to stay
in the topic of a crime because
it affects all of us governor burgum for
the first time ever a Univision poll
found that mass shootings and gun safety
are one of the most important issue for
Latino voters Doug mental health
concerns are not unique to the United
States but gone violence is
your specific plan to curb gun violence
if you just start speaking perfectly
first we notice to understand is I think
that the liberal oh no yeah he looks
like Scorsese left his seems to be just
completely bent on Prosecuting
law-abiding citizens that are gun owners
because every solution they have to this
is take away the Second Amendment rights
of Americans and somehow that's going to
solve the problem but all these cities
was that we're talking about that showed
the videos of tonight they have some of
the strictest gun laws in the country so
we know that that's not what's working
but we have to do is get back to the
courthouse shoes about the family we
have to get families behavioral health
and mental health we've got to get back
to actually enforcing the laws these
people talked about and like we've done
in North Dakota where we're we've got
the goal and we're on the track
military and the most support of what
we're doing in terms of law enforcement
because the the morale is down because
we've been defunding the police because
they've been attacked in the press the
police have become the bad guys when
they're the one they there's all these
jobs available in America why would you
be a policeman if people only respect
them every time I see a policeman the
first thing I say is thank you and so
does everybody else in my family and
most of the in our state because they
know we have to respect the people that
are out there defending us every single
day are you a burger Mania
90 of fentanyl is exist at official
border crossings and 57 percent of the
Smugglers are U.S citizens how would you
stop fentanyl brought into the country
mostly by U.S citizens through ports of
Entry there's two sides to this so we
have to be very honest about it one is
we do have to seal that southern border
building the wall is not enough they're
building cartel financed tunnels
underneath that wall semi trucks can
drive through them we have to use our
own military to seal the Swiss cheese of
a southern border but we also have to be
honest there's a demand side problem in
this country too a mental health
epidemic I met family in Iowa two
parents Kathy and Derek they lost their
son Sebastian 17 years old he bought
Percocet on Snapchat and then he died
why did he die because it was laced with
fentanyl that is closer to bioterrorism
not a drug overdose that is poisoning so
it is our job to make sure that never
happens but it's also our job to make
sure that 17 year don't turn to Percocet
via Snapchat we have to bring back
mental health care in this country not
with pump and pharmaceuticals but with
faith faith-based approaches that
restore purpose and meaning in the next
generation of Americans many of them are
getting it through social media and this
isn't a republican point or a Democrat
point but if you're 16 years old or
under you should not be using an
addictive social media product period
this is something that we can both agree
on and we can revive both the mental
health of this country while stopping
the fentanyl epidemic that will kill
more people this year than who died on 9
11 and I refuse to be a passive
bystander sitting in the White House
like the hollow husk of a current
President we have we will step up and
address this problem to stand for
Americans and our children
military to go after the Mexican drug
cartels they are killing our people and
the stories that I've seen in Florida we
had an infant 18 months parents rented
an Airbnb and apparently the people that
had read it before were using drugs the
infant was crawling the toddler was
crawling on the carpet and ingested a
fentanyl residue and died
are we just gonna sit here and let this
happen this Carnage happen in our
country I am not going to do that so I
guarantee you on day one this border is
going to be a day one issue for me as
president we're going to declare it a
National Emergency yes we'll build the
wall we'll do remain in Mexico but those
Mexican drug cartels are going to be
treated like the foreign
Obamacare mandates however you also made
that same promise in 2016.
time Trump Pence had Congressional
majorities for at least the first two
years and you did not deliver on that
promise so Obamacare right now it is
more popular than ever why should
Americans trust you if you become
president to fix that or is Obamacare
here to stay
well first let me speak to the mass
shootings issue and then I'll answer
that question it's important one Dana
it's the late is Justice denied
and as a father of three as the
grandfather of three beautiful little
girls under
I am sick and tired of these mass
shootings happening in the United States
of America if I'm president of the
United States I'm going to go to the
Congress of the United States and we're
going to pass a federal expedited death
penalty for anyone involved in a mass
shooting so that they will meet their
fate in months including gangs it is a
conscience
Kirkland shooter Ron is actually going
to spend the rest of his life behind
bars in Florida that's not Justice we
have to meet out Justice and send a
message to these would-be killers that
you are not going to live out your days
behind bars
does that mean Obamacare is here to stay
wow well thank you for reiterating the
question because
here you know my former running mate
Donald Trump
actually has a plan to to start to
consolidate more power in Washington DC
consolidate more power in the executive
branch if I'm president of the United
States it's my intention to make the
federal government smaller by returning
to the states those resources and
programs that are rightfully theirs
under the 10th Amendment of the
Constitution that means all Obamacare
funding all housing funding all HHS
funding all of it goes back to the
States
Department of Education will allow
states to innovate we're going to revive
federalism in America Democrats are
wielding corrupt power against us and
we're going to give all that power up as
soon as you vote for me no I'm not
interested sorry fire all of them get as
many questions I agree but first fire
them prosecute the sentence then start
breaking 26 million Americans
two and a half minutes
that's worse than the national average
can Americans trust you you want this
well I think this is a symptom of our
overall economic decline everything has
gotten more expensive you see insurance
rates are going through the roof people
that are going to get groceries I spoke
with a woman in Iowa and she said you
know for the first time in my life I'm
having to take things out of my grocery
cart when I get to the checkout line
because the the total goes up so quickly
so this is very real and people are
hurting out there so we've got to
address the underlying problem with
bidenomics the overspending taking all
Biden's rules and regulations I'm going
to throw them in the trash can on day
one you're not going to have to worry
about that we're going to open up all of
our energy we will be energy dominant in
this country that will lower your gas
prices and what we need to do with
Health Care is recognize our health care
is putting patients at the back of the
bus we have big Pharma big insurance and
big government and we need to tackle
that and have more power for the people
and the doctor-patient relationship why
is your record in Florida on insurance
worse than the national average our
state's a dynamic State we've got we've
got a lot of folks that come of course
we've had a population boom we also
don't have a lot of welfare benefits in
Florida you know we're basically say we
want to this is a Field of Dreams you
can do well in the state but we're not
going to be like California and have
massive numbers of people
um on government programs without work
requirements we believe you work and you
got to do that and so that goes for all
the welfare benefits and you know what
that's done Stuart our unemployment rate
is the lowest amongst any big state we
have the highest GDP growth events any
big state and even CNBC this is the
quickest I've ever seen him ranked on a
kind of unexpected
yeah
it's already locked up
clearing costs of bankruptcy for
American families accounting for
two-thirds of all personal bankruptcies
as president how you protect Americans
who get sick from Financial ruin
first of all how can we be the best
country in the world and have the most
expensive Health Care in the world we
have an issue my mom was in the hospital
when she was in the hospital they tried
to bring her a couple of Tylenol and she
said I don't need it and they said honey
go ahead and take it because you're
paying for it anyway why is it that when
we got the bill the insurance company
and the hospital negotiated the bill for
her without her having anything to do
with it when I am President we will
break all of it from the insurance
company to the hospitals to the doctor's
offices to the pbms to the
pharmaceutical companies we will make it
all transparent because when you do that
you will realize that's what the problem
is second thing is you've got to deal
with tort law the lawyer the doctors
don't give you the 10 tests because they
want to it's because of the 90 percent
chance they'll get sued and then we need
to bring competition back to health care
get rid of certificate of need systems
and make sure that they can compete we
have to put the patience is she running
for congress or is she running for the
President right yeah you know this is an
issue with their answers and
it's because the federal government got
involved the same way they did with EVs
and they said we're going to subsidize a
particular kind of software back in 2008
under Obama and they said hey we're
going to do this it's going to make
everybody more productive all of you
that are watching have been to a
doctor's office when the doctors got his
back to you and their hands on a
keyboard the the only industry in the
world that's ever absorbed one trillion
dollars
less patience because U.S health care
because they were subsidizing a certain
kind of Technology it was it wasn't
about improving health care it was about
picking winners and losers every time
the federal government's involved
whether it's higher education health
care or not the Auto industry things get
more expensive and less competitive
slaves
but he could provide that balance to
Trump right right the government you
know it's not the craziest idea I know
he's also extremely rich I got to say
this about uh Healthcare man
people are going to Mexico for
healthcare for real these people are
like everyone's going to Canada no
they're going to Mexico dude
I went to Mexico for my for my hip hip
problem and it's because it's cheaper
faster and better so my hip gets my hips
screwed up from a repetitive Sports
Injury I I call around these doctors you
get uh we don't take your insurance we
don't take your insurance and I'm just
like you this is the craziest thing
Michael I have to say this yeah I am
rich and I cannot go to a doctor and
this pissed me off that's insane it is
uh I called we have insurance I have
insurance we have the employees here
have insurance and I called the doctor
and I was like yeah I'm having an issue
uh uh respect Sports Injury we don't
accept your insurance and I'm like I'll
just pay you the money and they're like
no you can't do that and I'm like are
you kidding me I have money in my hand I
would like to give it to you call around
I find a specialist they say can you
come in in two weeks and I'm like this
is nuts man I'm like I want to get back
to skating as soon as I can and I need
to make sure I need to know if this is
like I need surgery is it a serious
injury it says tear or is it like take
aspirin and you're old right and
combination of both it wasn't a tear but
it's uh I skate too much I've seriously
screwed my hip up from falling for 20
years slamming it over and over and over
again causes like fluid to build up
that's why I only uh Razer Blade
that's when you mix it up with that
scooter too so uh we have all that stuff
we have we have BMX we have bikes we
have scooters we have blades but so uh
I get some advice from a good health uh
a a a trusted health professional friend
who says cellular performance Institute
they're in Tijuana
and I hit him up and they're like we can
have you out in two days immediately get
your MRI is done immediately get a
doctor consultation and give you the the
general treatments in a matter of days
after diagnosis and so the good news is
I did not need an uh hip injection I
actually just needed a general I just
got a generalized treatment and they
were like look you've got like traumatic
hip injury over the you're like we have
no recommendation for you just you know
like we're going to give you a general
revitalization I got like uh IV NAD stem
cells in general and it took one week
Luke was there I was there with my
girlfriend and it was
day one mri's done
in the United States it was can you come
in in two weeks for a consultation after
the consultation we'll schedule your
MRIs for a week later once your MRIs
come back a few days after that then
we'll start discussing treatment plants
all in all maybe in three or four months
we'll give you a general treatment for
and I'm like
that's crazy so are we gonna start
running across the border the other
direction how was that experience for
Mexicans
in terms of getting Healthcare is it
actually cheaper faster or better I mean
I believe you that it's cheaper and
faster but is it better
quality is yes so the the cellular
performance Institute is the
state-of-the-art highest end research
and the issue is that the amount of time
and money it takes to go through
clinical trials United States is
prohibitive yeah and so you've got
research coming out of universities
that's been tested been done it works
but now we got to do our multi-layered
test the United States you've got
revolving door policies you've got who's
Greece whose wheels are getting greased
things like this so but but let's not
even talk about the experimental medical
stuff Dental Care yeah yeah they they do
uh platelet-rich plasma uh I think it's
called yeah PRP so here's what happens
after you get say like a a a filling or
a root canal or whatever you got to do
your gums are all messed up they're sore
a few days later you're mostly fine what
they do in Mexico is they extract your
blood take platelet-rich plasma and
inject it around the site which rapidly
increases healing they don't for my
understanding is typically you don't get
that here in the United States not only
that it's it's like a couple hundred
bucks whereas like the United States
it's like a thousand two thousand in
Mexico of course they might also uh sell
your kidney so that while they're in
there you know they but you go to like
here's the thing man that's where my
mind goes when I think about how
Healthcare Works in other countries
that's not true though that's an
American style regulated it's an
American they want you to think
everywhere else was scary that's fine
yeah that's true do you know do you know
what time I I usually go to the dentist
why do you go
I'm sitting in this in this clinic in a
recliner chair looking at the beach in
Tijuana as dolphins are jumping in the
air and there's a seal on the ground I'm
like this is nuts that's pretty good and
they they bring so the that you get
breakfast and lunch as you're you're
like getting your IVs you're getting
your blood tests and all that stuff
you're sitting in this chair and they
bring fresh squeezed organic orange
juice all the food they make is organic
health food it's it's insane like I had
a salmon with like glaze glaze onion and
they're like oh it's it's wild fresh
salmon it's like you want to go on a
teeth cleaning vacation well this is
like hip problem this is uh two big
problems with our Health Care system is
it's it's so difficult to become a
doctor 15 years of net cost and then
it's the the easiest it is to get sick
poisonous food so you kind of gotta not
eat the poison that's the first step
we're back this has even been called
education homicide
you say school choice is the answer but
South Carolina your home state still has
not enacted Universal school choice and
even the current expansion won't be
fully implemented until 2027. wow
parents can't wait for years for a fix
so what would you do right now well in
school choice isn't the only answer but
I'll tell you it's not out of a lack of
trying that we didn't try and get school
choice in South Carolina what I'll tell
you first of all is we have to
acknowledge the fact that 67 percent of
our eighth graders are not proficient in
reading or math over 80 percent of our
eighth graders aren't proficient in
history or Civics and recently they came
out and said our 12 and 13 year olds are
scoring at the lowest levels they've
been scoring in reading and math in
decades so the first thing we've got to
do is we've got to make sure we catch
our kids back up we have to make sure
they can read a child that can't read by
third grade is four times less likely to
graduate high school we need to do
reading remediation we need complete
transparency in the classroom no parent
should ever wonder what's being said or
taught to their child in the class room
we need to make sure that we have school
choice so that there's competition we
need to move all so many rooms in the
federal government down to the States
decide what education looks like in
their states and we need to start
building things in America again let's
put vocational classes back in our high
schools and let's get our kids building
the things that we know that we can make
when we start to focus on that and
really bring in that parental
involvement that's when we'll start to
see a difference but we've got to get
parents back included we've got to quit
spending time on this Dei and CRT and
instead focus on financial literacy on
digital literacy and on making sure that
our kids know what they need to do to
have the jobs of the Next Generation
[Applause]
but minorities are not doing well with
math and reading Black and Hispanic
students averaging 29 Points lower than
white students in New Jersey would you
address minorities first
you have to address all students and
look in our states I don't want to take
debates thank you before I was governor
I was waiting foreign
schools and more Renaissance schools and
more public school choice in New Jersey
with innovative solutions in cities like
Camden where now we took what was the
worst school districts in America during
my time and we have now increased that
by nearly 40 percent in terms of their
proficiency it can be done when you give
people choice but let's tell the truth
to everybody about what this is this
public school system is no longer run by
the public it is run by the teachers
unions in this country Randy Weingarten
and her crew
are absolutely strangling they are
taking the worst of their members and
defending them rather than advocating
for our kids and when you have the
president United States sleeping with a
member of the teachers union there is no
chance that you could take the
Stranglehold away from the teachers
union every day they have an advocate
inside the White House every day for the
worst of their teachers not for our
students to be the best they can be a
president United States is to take on
the teachers union I did it in New
Jersey and I will do it as president of
the United States
oh my God slaves develop skills which in
some instances could be applied for
their personal benefit you have said
slaves develop skills yeah because of it
or yeah it might be in one of the others
for the sentence of slaves this is
personal
what is your message to them so first of
all that's a hoax that was perpetrated
by Kamala Harris we are not going to be
doing that second of all that was
written by descendants of slaves these
are great black history Scholars so we
need to stop playing these games here's
the deal our country's education system
is in decline because it's focused on
indoctrination denying parents rights
Florida represents the Revival of
American Education we're ranked number
one in the nation in education by U.S
news and World Report my wife and I we
have a six five and three year old this
is personal to us we didn't just talk
about Universal school choice we enacted
Universal school choice we didn't just
talk about parents Bill of Rights we
enacted the position's best issue we
eliminated Chris you know he gets a lot
of credit for kovid which people aren't
going to care about
in our school he's best on a big way
just like President Reagan as he had in
his fair better campaign strategy and
been in here and interviewed twice on
the show man he'd be the Front Runners
maybe not parents but kids are
benefiting
it's so sad that he's been underutilized
it's not just about if he came on this
show it's that if he was willing to come
on shows like this yeah yeah totally
he'd be doing he's a total yeah it's not
about us it's about him just taking it
long form interviews
on Earth
the decision people who are friends who
have been on the show already did you
talked about no longer education and
Healthcare we always think that those
issues go back to slavery here's the
challenge though black families survived
slavery we survived poll taxes and
literacy tests we survive discrimination
being woven into the laws of our country
what was hard to survive was Johnson's
Great Society where they decided
to put money
or they decided to take the black father
out of the household to get a check in
the mail and you can now measure that in
unemployment in crime and Devastation if
you want to restore hope you've got to
restore the family restore capitalism
and put Americans back at work together
as one American family our nation
continues to go in the right direction
it's why I can say I have been
discriminated against but America is not
a racist country never ever doubt who we
are we are the greatest country on God's
green earth and frankly the city on the
hill needs a brand new leader and I'm
over 10.7 million students 18 000 Public
Schools Nationwide have the ability to
change their identity without parental
notification Governor Christie told
Stewart last week that he would pass a
federal law to protect parental rights
would you try to do the same he can
barely hold it very clear about this
transgenderism especially in kids is a
mental health disorder we have to
acknowledge the truth of that for what
it is I met two young women early in
this campaign on parental rights in
school parents have the right to know
and you know what the hypocrisy of this
is even New Hampshire failed to actually
get past a piece of legislation here the
very people who say that this increases
the risk of suicide are also the ones
saying that parents don't have the right
to know about that increased risk of
suicide and I'm sorry it is not
compassionate to affirm none of us
imagine that is cruelty I met two young
women Chloe and Katie early in this
campaign who are in their 20s now regret
getting double mastectomies and a
hysterectomy one of them will never have
children and the fact that we allowed
that to happen in this country is
barbaric so I will ban genital
mutilation or chemical castration and
parents
parents should have that right we are
going to require States absolutely have
to follow that through Governor
because yes you you in your state this
is you do not have a lot of that parents
can't be notified but you want to be
president would you try to pass a
federal law to say parents have that
right I think this is a state's issue
but I do want to say something because
all night long we've been talking about
issues about how it's broken in
Washington and I respect all of the
people on the stage here for their 100
plus years of public service thank you
but the reason why we're not talking
about education
or safety being a problem
I've got more experience as a business
leader then I think this whole group
combined I know I've created more jobs
than everybody else thousands of
high-paying jobs that have real meaning
so as a business leader you come in and
you treat the taxpayer like a customer
so in North Dakota instead of fighting
with the teachers unions we actually
created a K-12 coordinating Council
everybody gets in the room and the
customer is the student I understand
that this is an issue that many people
in America really are concerned about
worried about about parents and
notification in schools yes and that's
why we have 50 platforms of innovation
that's why we have states there are
certain things the federal government is
supposed to do it's not the Department
of Education that needs to be assembled
we've got to move it back
instead of like oh here's a choice
every school got out from under the red
tape and the things that that help teach
the values that we're trying to get like
4-H like FFA like boys
dude Democrat let's think gay marriage
is a state's issue right exactly no
sorry
it was like he was fouling it off and
then he just struck out it
lgbtq plus people
add to me
his willingness to wear that hair like
that the entire tenure
and discrimination as president of the
United States I'll I'll stand up for the
safety uh and the civil liberties of
every American from every background and
I want the American people to know that
but I want to answer the question as
well as Dana that you just asked Doug
Burr because by way of full disclosure
Chris you mentioned the president's
situation I'm
my wife isn't a member of the teachers
union but I would met him so slow I've
been sleeping with a teacher and
um
look education is a state and local
function
the state of Indiana had one of the very
first school choice programs in the
country
that whole big thing about I don't go on
dinner dates with other women when the
Linden Community Schools and I have been
sleeping with every teacher in America I
can't get enough of them from your
parents to get a Tylenol but you could
get a gender transition plan without
notifying your parents I weighed in with
a foundation that's not bad policy
that's crazy we're going to stand up for
the rights of parents and we're going to
pass a federal ban on transgender
chemical or surgical surgery anywhere in
the country we've got to protect our
kids from this radical gender ideology
agenda and we've got to empower parents
at the state level with with the ability
to choose where their kids go to school
whether it's poorly articulated
parents to just redirect and say I just
want to talk about transgenderism
and focus on the basics faster than you
could possibly imagine next subjects
if you talk over everybody please lose
time
investing heavily companies two 180
billion dollars every year ON
Semiconductor research and development
that is one Chips act per year
Governor DeSantis you say companies like
Google and meta have too much power
doesn't going after them give China an
edge
no I think you look at how our societies
develop they have huge amount of power
over our society they've cracked down on
Free Speech uh we're not saying you
don't want them to do business but you
want it to be a free market and right
now they're monopolies but this issue of
China I think is really going to be
fundamental uh we have subcontracted out
so much of our national needs to the CCP
we rely on them for a whole host of
issues we need to reassure and we need
to decouple all those important
industries we need to get that back in
the United States they are our top
geopolitical adversary by a country mile
Gigi Ping's got huge Ambitions not only
in the Asia Pacific but as you mentioned
earlier in our region uh but ultimately
we've got to beat them on the economy
and so that's what we'll do as president
of the United States Governor Christie I
wanted
to a robot
you said in the past the free market is
the way to go would you retrain workers
who lose a job to artificial
intelligence and to do what
well look what I think artificial
intelligence offers us
is an extraordinary opportunity to
expand well beyond the productivity that
we have now and to have Americans be
able to invite be involved in that
Revolution Dana you know each time we
have shown incredible Innovation and
progress in this country what we've done
with it is to expand all kinds of new
even unthought of opportunities yes we
have to do retraining for folks who lose
some of their jobs and we should be
doing that and we should have more
training available both at the County
College level and the local level for
people to be able to access it so yes I
would be in favor of that but this is a
much bigger issue than that we can't be
afraid of innovation America has been
the great innovator of this world over
the last 250 years a technological
innovator a manufacturing innovator and
a freedom and governmental innovator and
that's why America has to continue to
stand strong in the world pro-innovation
pro-progress and I will tell you this as
president United States what I will do
is to make sure that every innovator in
this country gets the government the
hell off its back and out of its pocket
so that it can innovate and bring great
new inventions to our country that will
make everybody
Elon uh Elon announced tonight at
midnight he's gonna he's going to stream
a tier 99 nightmare dungeon speed run on
Diablo who's doing this Elon Musk I
wonder what class he is let's take bets
on my class it's a stressful
my guess is he's a sorcerer
so the answer is I have a radical idea
for the Republican party we need to win
elections how we win elections is
reaching the Next Generation
Democrats are running rampant reaching
the next generation three to one there's
exactly one person in the Republican
party which talks a big game about
reaching young people and that's me and
let me level with all of you I'm the new
guy here true and so I know I have to
earn your trust what do you see you see
a young man who's in a bit of a hurry
maybe a little ambitious a bit of a
know-it-all it seems at times I'm here
to tell you no I don't know it all I
will listen I will have the best people
the best and brightest in this country
whatever age they are advising me we
will be probably many of the people on
the stage included that's how I built my
companies I want to be challenged I want
people who disagree with me that's what
makes America great because we're not a
perfect Nation we're founded on the
pursuit of perfection
infuriating because Tick Tock is one of
the most dangerous social media apps
that we could have and what you've got I
honestly every time I hear you I feel a
little bit Dumber for what you say
because
that was a stupid situation what they're
doing is these 150 million people are on
Tick Tock that means they can get your
contacts they can get your financial
information they can get your email
thank you let me just say text messages
in China not America excuse me I wanted
kids to go and get on the social media
that's dangerous you when you were in
business with the Chinese that gave 100
5 million dollars we can't trust you
at least
15 seconds
15 seconds Mr rameshwari thank you I
think we would be better served as a
Republican party if we're not sitting
here hurling personal insults and
actually have a legitimate debate
I believe in these
across Europe cheated on arms control
treaties with the U.S and seeks to work
with China to force our decline
President Reagan believed that if you
want to prevent a war you better be
prepared to fight one today the
Republican party is at odds over Aid to
Ukraine the price tag so far is 76
billion dollars
but is it in our best interest to
degrade Russia's military for less than
five percent of what we pay annually on
defense especially when there are no U.S
soldiers in the fight it's in our
interest to end this war and that's what
I will do as President we are not going
to have a blank check we will not have
U.S troops and we're going to make the
Europeans do what they need to do but
they've sent money to pay uh bureaucrats
pensions and salaries and funding small
businesses Halfway Around the World
meanwhile our own country is being
invaded we don't even have control of
our own territory we have got to defend
the American people before we even worry
about all these other things and I
watched these guys in Washington DC and
they don't care about the American
people they don't care about the
fentanyl deaths they don't care about
the communities being overrun because of
this border they don't care about the
Mexican drug cartels so as
commander-in-chief I will defend this
country's sovereignty but it's not
it's never been a territorial dispute
and 90 of the resources that we send
over to Ukraine is guaranteed it's a
loan it is not 90 of the money that we
send over there is loan well we can talk
about this but at the end of the day 90
of the money that we send over there
let's debate the fact that our national
vital interests is in degrading the
Russian military now
we actually keep our homeland safer we
keep our troops at home and we all
understand Article Five of NATO with the
American people I thought you said
something about waiting until you return
to talk so well so at the end of the day
and I'll respond I've been looking
forward to this one right now um so at
the end of the day when you think about
the fact if you want to keep American
troops at home
the attack on NATO territory would bring
us and our troops in by degrading the
Russian military we reduce if not
eliminate a an attack
against that exchange we have to level
with the American people we have to
level with the American people on this
issue the reality is just because just
because Putin is not and Putin's an evil
dictator does not mean that Ukraine is
good this is a country that has banned
11 opposition parties
excuse me
you like China yeah
[Music]
this was like to end this especially in
this country whose president just last
week
to take Taiwan we need to peace
[Music]
are we focused too much on Ukraine and
not enough on this threat from the New
World Order no they're all connected
Stewart they're all connected Chinese
weapons and so are the North Koreans now
as well with the encouragement of the
Chinese the naivete on this stage from
some of these folks is extraordinary
look
I understand people want to go and talk
to Putin guess what so did George W bush
so did Barack Obama
so did Donald Trump and so did Joe Biden
when he said a small Invasion wouldn't
be so bad every one of them has been
wrong
and the fact of the matter is we need to
stay right now
that the Chinese Russian Alliance is
something we have to fight against and
we are not going to solve it by going
over and cuddling up to Vladimir Putin
Trump also wasn't wrong Trump said
Vladimir Putin Putin didn't invade
further into any country Donald Trump
was President his strategy actually
worked perfect who is murdering people
in his own country and now not having
enough blood he's now going to Ukraine
to murder innocence
next will be Poland this is a guy who
said this is a guy in 1991 who said that
was the darkest moment world's history
when the Soviet Union fell listen
everybody he wants to put the old band
back together and only America can stop
it and we're not President we will
and we need to talk about America's
Farmers because there is a foreign
policy connection here the U.S and China
are in this Fierce economic competition
it's hurting American businesses and
there is blowback against American
farmers because China then targets them
in retaliation how would you as
president protect American farmers and
ranchers from that kind of retaliation
from a foreign government like China
well first of all we've got the best
farmers and ranchers in the world right
here in America if they have a Level
Playing Field they can out-compete
anyone in the world but this is part of
the larger issue that we're talking
about here which is we're in a cold war
with China the Biden Administration
won't admit that but we're also in a
economic War through the what we're
doing with Agriculture and energy and
we're also in a war with them relative
to cyberware we get attacked every day
in North Dakota every state every school
district our tribes all being attacked
every day by either China Russia Iran or
North Korea and now we've got a Biden
Administration whose whole policy is
appeasement they're out there you know
creating the world making it less safe
six billion dollars they traded for five
people they've just now set a price on
anyone's head who's a tourist from
America who's a student from America for
kidnapping if you want more kidnapping
put a price on it and then that's and
they're also helping Iran get to have
more closer to nuclear weapon than which
pushes all of the Middle East closer to
China and Russia the whole thing is
absurd and then of course we're going to
give Ukraine to Russia and then we're
going to give Taiwan to China and think
that's a foreign policy that will make
our nation less less successful make us
more poor and at the core of all that is
energy policy because China Imports 10
million barrels of oil a day they're the
largest import in the world and we've
had four cabinet members from the Biden
Administration there this summer and
none of them talked about U.S energy the
first one to go to each of those
countries was Carrie to talk about the
Folly of the climate climate policy
which is making the world less stable
it's empowering dictators it's not about
climate change that we need to worry
about it's about the Biden climate
policies that are actually the
existential threat to America's future
Mexico he didn't win me back with that
one we've got Scotch yeah
more sophisticated
Mexico is the United States most
important
and border security
you say you will send Special Operations
to attack the cartels in Mexico so this
means boots on the ground
drone strikes
it means Special Operations that's how
we deal with our terrorists and what you
need to do is understand that Mexico is
not being a good partner if we lost 75
000 Americans last year Mexico's not
being a good partner if they're letting
the cartels get away with what they're
getting away with what we will do is we
will make sure that we send in our
special operations and we will take out
the cartels we'll take out their
operations we'll take out anything
that's doing it but we're going to go
after a child because China is she's
literally just saying she wants military
operations and we will end all normal
trade relations until China stops
sending and then we'll do it she's
literally just saying she just said that
she wants to send specifications when
President Trump went wrong
that's more reasonable than Ukraine
focus on the facts
she looks like she's amazed constantly
and we've got all these little
surveillance cells we need to start
focusing on what keeps us that hasn't
happened in a long time as your
president I will make sure every
American is safe and will do whatever it
takes to make that Michael is a man of
finer tastes he went to the Laphroaig
27. this is that's a good one this is
much better than this debate Edition I
know that's what I offer in the United
States
what you guys do backstage the backstage
they just started one that's very
similar to Backstage yeah
[Laughter]
nearly 3 000 lives
and the farther we get from September
11th the closer we are to September 10th
Senator Scott you have no executive
branch experience
what has prepared you to protect the
nation from a majority
of National Security crisis
on committees and
in life
also in the finance committee and the
Banking Committee talk about addressing
the issue of fentanyl I've written the
legislation passed it through the
Banking Committee and the Senate that
would freeze the assets and sanction the
accounts of the Mexican cartels there
are weapons that we have within the
Arsenal that I was able to get past 23-0
in the polarizing Senate as it is I've
also understood without question the
fact that if you look at the details
before 9 11 there was information and
intelligence that was available that
suggested an attack was coming having
the right intelligence partners with us
is key to making sure that we prevent
the next 9 11 from ever happening having
that experience for the last 10 years is
really important in getting the job done
you want to increase domestic spying in
response to September 11th well I think
you asked a question about executive
experience I think it's vitally increase
the security
tonight you hear the fire in all of our
voices and it's because Joe Biden is
weak in this country at home and abroad
this is a time for those of us that have
the experience
the tested experience and a commitment
to the conservative agenda that Ronald
Reagan brought forward in this party of
a strong National Defense standing with
our allies standing up to our enemies
supporting limited government and
Traditional Values need to step forward
understand because frankly our party
does face a time for children
whether we're going to follow the siren
song of populism on more to conservative
principles
Trump's ability to hire and I'm ready
choosing to go to a break I need to go
to a commercial break room no Jack the
sub has got a really good tweet he says
over one hour in and not one candidate
has even mentioned the Biden doj
weaponizing the power of the state to
take down his top opponent
I just look man I like the vague but if
I was on that stage I'm sorry anybody
watches this show like you know exactly
what you talking about I would the first
thing they'd say they'd say we have an
immigration crisis the Border as
president what would you do out
you gotta go you can't stay you came
here illegally we're gonna get you on a
nice bus we're going to send you back to
Mexico Mexico and deal with it they
broke into Mexico or they're from Mexico
they come here well they go back to
Mexico I don't hate the people I got no
beef in fact I respect their drive to
come to the greatest country on this
planet sorry but you can't stay apply
legally we'll welcome you in in due time
so we can adequately and properly handle
the economics next Point as president
all prosecution anybody who engaged in a
prosecution or sedition against the
previous president will face criminal
prosecution next question I'm I'm done
they're up there and they're being like
well let's have a debate on the merits
of China dude
yeah we get it they're arresting the
opposition later man you know like but
we can talk about China yeah we can talk
about China yes we realize China's a
threat next question well what would you
do about it the first thing I would do
is stop the Psychopaths who are
dissolving Trump's business falsely
accusing him of rape Prosecuting his
lawyers
you think anyone in this country right
now look what they're trying to do
is they're trying to
this is the problem with with
conservative voters or I shouldn't it's
the right it's that there's this hope
and this belief that if you just do
nothing it goes back to normal not the
case not gonna happen so what's gonna
happen is after Trump is gone you've now
proven they can wield these tactics
against anyone who stands in their way
yep that this is what what is so funny
about this thing tonight is there are
some good answers I think DeSantis is
doing a good job relative to the last
one I think uh Nikki's relative yeah but
relative is the key word for all of this
here Nikki started out strong against
her opponents she she got weaker
throughout same thing with Tim Scott
even bergam lost me he lost me even Doug
burgum but but the reason I say relative
is
words because none of their names is
Donald John Trump who is 50 points ahead
of everybody but they could make it
matter it's just what they're doing is
your run-of-the-mill blah blah blah
political debate yeah what did Donald
Trump do I will arrest Hillary Clinton
he didn't do it he didn't and so you go
up on that stage and what do people want
to hear well look
what they're trying to do
all of these people
I imagine most of them don't actually
believe a word they say yeah what
actually happens is the Consultants come
in and say if you go with these talking
points you'll cast a wider net than Ron
DeSantis will so that's why Nikki Haley
was like you want to get kids on The
Tick Tock he literally said we should
not allow them on Tick Tock and then you
just said nonsense because they don't
actually believe or care about whatever
it is they're talking about there also
appears to be just real personal
animosity now which there wasn't at the
last debate I think so it's this is the
part that I really like about the
campaign season is when they actually
start to just like hate each other and
and they can't keep it in anymore
because I just want something unexpected
I want some sign of life and or an
organic reaction to human beings and so
you're starting to see that a little bit
here but it still seems like play acting
to me I mean agreed for someone it's six
percent to say when I'm president of the
United States you know give me a break
you know what you know what answer I
would appreciate more than any one of
these answers when asked right now
Donald Trump the former president is
facing multiple indictments there there
is a an investigation into the son of
the president which may involve the
president himself how would you respond
when Ian says I'd pardon all of them so
we can end the animosity in fighting
while I disagree with it it's a real
answer yeah yeah it's not a well you got
to understand investigations need to be
played out and as the American people no
no Ian will tell you what he wants to do
even if you don't like what he wants to
do these people will tell you
wishy-washy BS nonsense and waste our
time they should be talking about
hydrogen fuel the evolution of our fuel
since they should talk about graphene
and the industrialization
about graphene all night can you imagine
it's not one sadness we're here in
California where gas is nearing six
dollars a gallon oil is close to a
hundred dollars a barrel again you say
drill better drill that was a good
timing actually Mr ramashwami how would
you bring down
well look I think that we do have to run
through the courts and get through that
administrative state to make sure we're
using the natural resources here at home
but here's the other thing that we can
do that's easy forever and IT addresses
the national debt as well
people it's funny because it gets them
to correctly pronounce we are using
taxpayer money to pay people people more
to stay at home than to go to work that
is wrong that contributes to our supply
chain crisis it contributes to his
inflation that's the easiest way to
unlock this autonomy and here's the
other thing we have to put the Federal
Reserve back in its place this is an
agency that has gone Rogue so in January
2026 when I have the opportunity as our
next commander-in-chief we will have a
new chairman of the Federal Reserve 26.
places priority on dollar stability
send packing 75 percent of the
administrative State reduce the federal
employee head count by 75 percent
rescind 50 percent of unconstitutional
federal regulations that are shackling
businesses both large and small I've
offered a very clear practical plan to
do it that's how we unleash the economy
see this is what's refreshing about him
all these other candidates are just
repeating the same old craps in the 80s
and what Trump did in 16 was he had a
new plan yeah and vivek's got a new plan
[Music]
we became a net exporter of energy for
the first time in 75 years
he didn't do that Joe Biden declared a
war on energy which was no surprise
because when Joe Biden ran for president
he said he was going to end fossil fuels
and they've been working overtime to do
that ever since if I'm president of the
United States
we're going to unleash I like that
American Energy
above energy strategy and I have a plan
that actually would not only reclaim
energy Independence but in in 2006
America lost our position as the leading
producer on Earth
says credit where it's due this is one
of the most entertaining model U.N
debates I've ever seen
producer on
Earth
who is against energy Independence
Rhonda santis is against fracking I
think this hurts because she she was in
the last bit she was the stable adult
when she started out that way yeah now
she's like really going after him
day two in Florida
you did it on Federal Land she's going
for the uh act erratically that way when
they criticize you you can claim their
sexist
I just did a plan out in West Texas for
American Energy dominance we're going to
choose Midland over Moscow we're going
to choose the Marcellus over the molas
and we're going to choose Bakken over
Beijing and we are going to lower you
because it's important for our national
security it's important for jobs and
that's one of the best ways to drive
down inflation I I've written lines that
I was waiting because I thought they'd
kill but so you know have you noticed
that Ron's smiling a bit when he's not
talking you mentioned that it's because
the last debate he did that weird like
wince yeah and it went viral yeah yeah
yeah but it still looks like that I'm
totally wrong they voted today that's
what we did onshore we do do it in
Florida yeah
so that's just wrong and let's just get
real here my plan will get the job done
we are going to be entering dominant and
that's what's going to happen and why
are they
the Trump's calling it like 72 percent
it's like it's like the vice president's
base
yeah
this is your question
the Biden Administration is hell-bent on
student loan forgiveness but you say
colleges should be on the hook when
graduates cannot pay their debt how does
that address the cost of college how do
that the cost of college itself because
the colleges are going to have to make a
decision do we offer do we expand the
gender studies Department knowing some
of those graduates may not have great uh
learning opportunities no they're going
to focus on the things that really
matter they're going to make different
choices they're going to try to graduate
people in four years I also just want to
come back something Dana asked last
segment about 9 11 because I was just at
the 911 memorial with the families my
wife and everybody is very touching to
be there and it affected my life because
I ended up joining the military as a
result of that I had been a blue collar
kid his careers
oh no somehow someone's going to make
the Conservative then when I went in and
that is not easy to do had a lot of
opportunities to make money but I wanted
to serve and I'll never forget
what is interesting Landing in Coronado
California
and I think being able to serve and I'll
be the first president elected since
1988 who's actually served overseas in a
war you know I think that's going to
help me as commander-in-chief to know
how you see these issues and understand
that there are real lives at stake for
people that wear the uniform and we know
that Governor Haley's husband is serving
right now as well and we thank him for
that like Dana just 3ms the Haley
Interruption the approval rate for
Congress is at a mere 19 good If This
Were a business you'd probably all be
fired in Washington but you're here
tonight looking for a promotion in 2013.
I'm not going to tell her why you should
be promoted to CEOs
just insult all of them all one of the
things I'd say is if you look at our
national debt 33 trillion dollars
a balanced budget just a mimic that
would constrain the spending in
Washington in the same fashion that it
does in every state in our nation number
one number two if you want to actually
reduce our nationality
about 10 million jobs
you can do that in three specific
sectors number one the energy sector we
could create between three and three and
a half million jobs if we unleash
someone's gonna do like a song with this
clip right here they say we're the
richest country
gas and oil why not unleash all of our
resources number two we've lost a
hundred thousand factories a hundred
thousand factories in the last 25 years
if we continued on my made in America
plan we could bring jobs back to America
in a similar fashion that we did when I
wrote the tax cuts and jobs Act we
actually lowered the corporate tax from
35 to 21 reassured or repatriated 1.7
trillion dollars we brought the
unemployment rates for African-Americans
Hispanics and Asians to the lowest level
in the history of the country and a
70-year low for women Governor Haley
would you think you think you would
deserve the promotion I think look I I
appreciate Tim we've known each other a
long time but he's been there 12 years
and he hasn't done any of that he hasn't
they've only given four budgets on time
big victories for the people what's the
point and that's what it's all about out
you can always talk but when when it
gets hot in there when they're shooting
arrows at you are you going to be stand
up for parents rights to keep the state
free are you going to be able to do all
those things and in the State of Florida
because of our success the Democratic
party lies in Ruins we have won the big
fights we have turned our state into a
Republican state peace leadership like
Biden won the debates in 2020. which is
if he didn't win it by being soaring and
exceptional and spectacular he just won
it by being the least like wacky person
up there budgeting That's the Way
businesses are actually start with zero
as the Baseline
necessary there isn't blue state or a
red state in this Union that doesn't the
federal government doesn't do it but
successful companies including the ones
that I've built he's done very well for
all the attacks the way he speaks the
way he did his hair all plans he's going
for a cartoonish personality like Trump
I think yeah
not just not as silly as Trump is but
he's trying to character like make a
character of himself you know that's a
good observation these other folks on
stage we're already doing it in North
Dakota the Border plans are already
talking about we've got troops down at
the border flying helicoptions
North Dakota criminal organizations from
inflicting The Invasion and the mass
casualties in our state and on the
energy policy we're already doing it
it's not saying when nobody else done
the big fights North Dakota was leading
the charge we won the battle to get the
Biden Administration who was ignoring
the law they were the first
Administration since Truman that wasn't
holding the quarterly required lease
sales and we won that in federal court
wotus we won that in federal court we're
fighting the Biden Administration on 20
fronts to say that nobody's fighting the
big fights just look at the record of
what we're doing right now energy
economy National Security have been
talking about it since day one and now
finally good we're having the
conversation about it but we've got the
answer in North Dakota governor I've
said it for years governments North
Dakota just for you has the answer the
government keeps getting bigger
one-fifth of all new jobs this year have
been created by the government Governor
burgum you say you want to shrink the
size of government but it has been a
century because my president has done
that why would you be any different well
because we're doing we've doing we've
done it in North Dakota when I took
office We Shrunk the state budget
general fund by 27 in the first four
months I was office and we all the
trains still running on time why because
you had a business leader that was
actually there inside of interesting
Mussolini reference there's 10 or 20
percent approval of mind-numbing
soul-sucking work that even the state
and federal employees don't want to do
and you can engineer that work out of
the job that would free up right there
at 20 of 2 million civilian employees
and by the way we've got 10 million jobs
open they'd have plenty to do and they
could be in generating taxes instead of
being paid by taxes this is totally
possible to do it if you have somebody
that understands because having worked
in technology for 30 years everything we
had to do was to be better faster and
cheaper than next day that's what we can
do in government that's what we're doing
in North Dakota all right Governor
DeSantis Michael malice's Porky Pig
attacks Donald Duck ask you about
something that is on a lot of
Republicans Minds this election could
come down to less than 50 000 votes in
three states that's right abortion was
on the bench in Six States in 2022
Republicans lost all of them
next year abortion will likely be on the
ballot in Arizona that is a must Nikki
Haley to just sit down how are you going
to win over independent pro-choice
voters in Arizona same way we did in
Florida we won the greatest Republican
victory in a Governor's race and the
history of the state over 1.5 million
votes we were winning places like
Miami-Dade County Palm Beach that nobody
thought was possible because we were
leading with purpose and conviction I
reject this idea that pro-lifers are to
blame for midterm defeats I think
there's other reasons for that the
former president
um you know he's missing in action
tonight he's had a lot to say about that
he should be here explaining his
comments to try to say that pro-life
protections are somehow a terrible thing
I want him to look into the eyes and
tell the people who've been fighting
this fight for a long time I was at my
wife and I earlier today were at the
gravesite of President Mrs Reagan and I
noticed that there was a quote where it
says every single person has per purpose
and worth we're better off when
everybody counts and I think we should
stand for what we believe in I think we
should hold the Democrats accountable
for their extremism supporting abortion
all the way up until the moment of birth
that is in fantaside and that is wrong
if this referendum is on the ballot
there yeah because I did it in New
Jersey Dana you know it's been one of
all these other states losing well
because they don't have leaders in those
States who are leading the fight the way
it should be led and in fact
is really tough for republicans and
those are the states that we're gonna
have to try to win if we're going to win
the White House back and what we did was
14 times Dana in eight years I vetoed
planned parenthood funding 14 times
no one else gets it that much the
Democrats just kept sending it to me and
I kept saying no because I believe in
life but I also believe in states rights
and I think we've fought hard against
Roe versus Wade for decades to say that
states should make these decisions so
we're going to have those fights I
believe in life and I believe that
California should kill as many babies as
they want because I'm a principal
conservative you have to be proactive
abortion as a Federalists in the womb
and we talked a lot about fentanyl
tonight and we haven't spoken one moment
about treatment
but we need to make sure that for the
drug addicted 16 year old on the floor
of the County lockup we her life is
Precious too and we need to be providing
treatment to cure this as a disease that
it is if you're pro-life you've got to
be pro-life for the entire life we start
talking like that they're going to do
what I did in the blue state which was
get reelected with 61 percent of the
vote and won 70 percent of Independence
and 51 of Latinos because I told them
the truth from my heart to polarized
the latest Univision pool found that 73
of Latino voters think the Republican
party doesn't care about or is being
hostile toward them the Hispanic
Community only Governors
I like it how would you reach out to
Latino voters
well I I promise you that we're going to
continue to build Bridges to every
community in this country I just wish
you went out and I'm incredibly I don't
care citizens
Protestants so I think the president of
the United States needs to be a champion
for the American dream for every
American it begins with The Unborn and
the aging and the infirm and it begins
with every ethnic group in this country
and I promise you if I'm president of
the United States I'll Be A Champion
I'll Be A Champion
for Hispanic Americans and forever he
was just like I'm not going to win
everybody knows it yes we're just up
here
if you lead by example it's the best way
to get the job done if you look at my
office in the Senate my chief of staff
is the only Hispanic female Chief of
Staff in the Senate I hired her because
I think Trump would ever hold his
qualified personally
I really wish I could be on the stage
guys
just since everyone's listening to me
like I'm voting for Trump I'm up here to
tell you I'm voting for Trump and y'all
can't beat them I'd probably get up
there let's say hey no one up on the
stage which is why I'd encourage you to
purchase my book speechless controlling
words
U.N Ambassador you literally the
knowledge has left me speeches
location
next you got bad information first of
all I fought the gas tax in South
Carolina multiple times against this
let's go to YouTube against the
establishments
shut up when they wouldn't pass the gas
tax establishment the companies wanted
me to do it so much
adoption and income tax then I will look
at your guests
secondly on the curtains do your
homework
did you send them back it's in there did
you send them back it's the state
department
you should tell her to calm down the
point where you need Alex Jones to go
you should be like you sound crazy right
this is when Trump would walk in yeah
this was actually a movie what if all of
a sudden the lights go out yeah
Trump walks in
when she said that she was Dumber for
having listened to Vivek the reality is
I'm Dumber for having listened to all of
them you know when when she was going
after Scott and it's just the same thing
they're both they've been sniping at
everyone all night but then when Scott
just totally lost even the veneer did
you send him back what's good what's
good you send it back or not and then
she goes did you send him back did you
yeah wow that's what I'm like you need
Macho Man to like storm with a chair I
know you are but what am I I know you
are was it you Tim
what do you guys said that for Vegas too
smart do you think it's actually
literally he's literally too smart to
represent a stupid populace yes you need
a stupider person to represent we've had
smart presidents Vivek is uh uh he's
doing really really well but he my
advice then would be he's trying to
Target audiences like ours too much the
people who listen to the show are so
well read they correct Us in the
comments yeah when we get things wrong
if you're trying to get a a general
swath of as many people as possible he
needs to tone it down a little bit to
where the people who watch her like this
understand what he's saying and like I
totally get it but it's like cake
something simple and easily digestible
not some complicated dish that's super
like oh actually oatmeal is a better way
to put it you know like with some brown
sugar on top super easy to make
everybody gets it it's oatmeal anybody
can do it the thing about Vivek is an
exceptional guy in every way I mean this
was true when I was in college he was
like known as even at Yale law school
best law school in the country he was
like a top guy on he was a big man on
campus and he's always been very
impressive and exceptional and
but everyone knows it whereas someone
like Trump
has always been more exceptional than
just about any public figure in the
United States I mean he's whether you
love him or hate him the guy has been a
rock star celebrity for 40 years in what
like five Industries he's tried he was
in real estate then he tries out Network
TV becomes the top rated show then he
runs for president wins on his first try
I mean it's totally exceptional but it
he doesn't seem that way he seems like a
normal guy who eats Big Mac he makes it
look easy and Vivek is just he he's very
like high strung he Yeah well yeah just
he just reads as
the Yale law school you know smart
wealthy guy which is which is impressive
but if he could if he could be that guy
and eat the Big Macs that would be well
done steak with ketchup that's right but
this is why when fetterman I guess
someone was super chatting they got rid
of the uh they reinstated the dress code
like fetterman stopped wearing shorts
you hear a slob uh my attitude when it
came to fetterman was yeah I don't think
shorts are appropriate but I certainly
think it's silly that everyone has to
wear a suit and like women have to wear
dresses or whatever and it was the it's
the right being like no there has to be
a dress code like a blah blah and like
there are some people who I know that
are not even super conservative but
they've become tribal I'll agree with
the right on this for no reason and I'm
like listen
I agree the shorts and the hoodie it's a
little bit too much so much yeah but
Donald Trump ate a 30-day dry aged steak
well done with ketchup and was mocked
and ridiculed by the Press why I I love
this talking point regular people yeah
who aren't Michelin chefs just want to
cook a nice steak for their family and
they and they buy what they can buy from
Walmart and they like to cook it well
done with ketchup it is it is a lower
class thing not all low-class people
low-class people eat this way I know
that there are people who work really
really hard they don't make a lot of
money and they and they learn how to
cook a steak properly But Me growing up
my dad would cook great steaks and then
sometimes we get the dollar stakes and
we could come throw and splop clutch
ketchup yeah so when Trump does that and
the media insulted Trump they were
insulting all of us yeah yeah when
fetterman dresses down they're trying to
play the same game to get conservatives
to appear elitist in 4020 and you have
to dress in a suit right right is that
great is it true that he was wearing the
hoodie to cover up that bulge on the
back of his mask that's correct I love
the conspiracy theory that that's not
really Federate anymore like it really
obviously is him the Federer men the
multiple better man I have I've been
watching old videos of Donald Trump
lately they've just been popping up in
my feeds here and there and he was
prolific and and actually very
intelligent yeah like I think you make a
good point earlier he comes off as kind
of a I mean I will say he comes off as a
doofus because that's the way the
media's been portraying and look at that
idiot they can't tweet properly yeah but
he's very smart very very smart guy
Taylor Swift right
everybody starts ragging on Taylor Swift
all of a sudden because she's dating
that football player guy and I see
people saying like her music sucks and
I'm like her music does not suck and she
works really hard and there are people
who claim are claim that her music sucks
and she doesn't work hard because they
want to hate her and I'm like dude they
said Donald Trump was a and he's a
billionaire he's certainly smarter than
you yeah they say he doesn't work hard
he certainly Works harder than you you
don't have to like Taylor Swift or like
her music I don't but I know that the
people who love it it's because it is
good and and it's a product being sold
yeah what if if you know if you said the
product is bad I'm like well she just
sold a billion of them right like
certainly people enjoy it yeah love song
I thought that song was rock star all
right
hopefully it's over in front of you 15
seconds starting now
[Music]
what is your mathematical path yes
Governor DeSantis
in order to try to beat president Trump
who has a commanding and enduring lead
in this race
don't elect presidents voters and we're
going to take voters
we're going to do in a state-by-state
direction as Reagan said in his day this
is our time for choosing we are not
getting a mulligan on the 2024 election
Republicans have lost three straight
elections in a row we're supposed to
have a red wave with inflation at nine
percent it crashed and burned not in
Florida it didn't we delivered it in
Florida and so we've got to choose right
we've got to win and we need somebody
that's going to be able to serve two
terms so in January of 2023 they'll be
able to address the nation saying we
turn the economy around we secured the
board January
as your president
I believe I did see you write something
on the card
oh hell but I'll certainly tell you go
okay yeah what look I think I've been
the only one in this stage that's been
clear about this I vote Donald Trump off
the island right now
and the reason I vote him off the island
well I guess the question was who would
you vote on
every person on this stage has shown the
respect for Republican voters to come
here to express their views honestly
candidly and directly and to take your
questions honestly I have respect for
every man and woman on this stage
because they've not put your hand down
for a second would you
um
he's divided families all over this
country he's divided friends all over
this country
who have sad at Thanksgiving dinner or
at a birthday
anymore if they disagree with Donald
Trump's father
was an excellent president but the
America First agenda does not belong to
one man it does not belong to Donald
Trump it doesn't belong to me it belongs
to you the people of this country and
the question is who's going to unite
this country and take the America First
agenda to the next level when we rallied
behind the cry to make America great
again we did not just hunger for a
single man we hungered for the
Unapologetic pursuit of Excellence so
yes I will respect Donald Trump and his
legacy because it's the right thing to
do but that's the only guy wearing a
millennial America first it's a
tailoring very Millennial the rest are
all wearing potatoes that's
that's it
loved having you here man that was so
dumbass no final statements
they were gonna replace it with lift up
the card who do you vote off Donald
Trump did not cause the division Donald
Trump is an avatar of the rage felt by
Americans correct the division had
already existed I just I would I would
love to uh you see where we we we're
working on hosting some kind of debate
uh the problem is none of them will
actually Vivek will do it yeah right I'm
not saying we've confirmed with debate
I'm saying based on what we know of
vivek's willingness to come on and have
these conversations he's the kind of guy
who was willing to be like let's sit
down let's have this conversation
totally but you're not going to get a
Democrat and you're not going to get any
of these other Republicans to do it I
wonder if we could get um Kennedy have
you talked to Kennedy Robert Kennedy oh
you know I have even though he uh I grew
up in the town that he lived in I was
aware of Bobby Kennedy Jr for much of my
upbringing and I always thought he was a
crazy lib and he still sort of is a
crazy limb but politics is so nuts now
that he's kind of on our side anyway
he's still polling it like 19 I think
yeah have you guys talked to him anybody
at Daily wire interviewed him I have a
chance I haven't one of them may maybe
Candace would be likely I don't remember
though I have hopes that he would come
on and debate yeah he would we know he
would we've talked with people just it's
an issue of scheduling there's a lot of
really high profile people that we're
just working scheduling out with because
everyone's super busy like Doug burgum
Burger Mania man yeah the challenge so
the issue I take with this and the
reason why they wouldn't come on this
show
establishment unibody Republicans and
Democrats wouldn't come on a show like
this because they can't stand up to
scrutiny yeah The Vape would come on a
show like this because he can right I
say hey Vivek here's like when when he
was accused of the sorrow stuff funding
he made a video immediately posted and
said guys let me address that for you
like I'll talk about it because you this
is what you have to do
Trump goes on tons of podcasts and he
just sits there and he talks he calls
into Fox News he just Rambles yeah that
works that's better so there's there's
people who can do it better than Trump
for sure but like when Chris Christie's
like Trump divided this country and
there were friends who were fighting
with each other it's just like shut up
dude that's not true and we're tired of
listening to the but also like
if my crazy you know purple-haired third
cousin and twice removed doesn't want to
speak to me anymore because I voted for
Trump then that's that's her fault
that's her problem did you see the the
there's a viral Reddit post where a
woman said she broke up with her
boyfriend because she found out he
listens to Andrew Tate well oh yes and
she's like I couldn't believe he was
like that and it's like he never argued
with you he never insulted you or fought
with you or did anything wrong he never
sold you for sex no never you know she
just found out that because he listened
to Andrew Tate it meant that he was a
homophobic she had to break up with him
that dude's probably like oh wow yeah
sure okay
that her takeaway was that oh he's a
homophobe
what all these things yeah well that
that about wraps up the horrible
lesser-known GOP debate uh thanks for
hanging out everybody we will of course
be back tomorrow with more shows so
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com this
Miami event is going to be super epic we
uh I believe it is it is confirmed we're
going to be doing Friday night's show
that we normally do it's going to be on
timcast.com members only uh that way it
can be the most based version of what
this show can be with people like James
O'Keefe Patrick Bet David Matt Gates
especially with Matt Gates we're just
going to be alike have fun say it all
and I I think it for the most part it's
just a means of helping support the
website doing these events is is an
effective way of just growing the
business so really do appreciate
everybody who supports us as members and
everybody's gonna be coming
um so yeah uh Michael do you want to
shout anything out you know I do
I've got a secret project I'm working on
at the daily wire that I can't say
anything about so the shout out is going
to be
no comment but stay tuned it's going to
be really good
how you like that wow is that an
effective promotion core oh also there's
one other product
um if you're if you're a fan of reading
or literature you can purchase my book
speechless controlling words controlling
mine it's available now wherever you
know people still post super chats do
they
it's it's like a meme on our show that
is to get me great thank you very much
your first book was a huge hit as well
that also was uh twice now best-selling
author once with words yeah I like it
what's the name of the first book uh
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guy I'm gonna have a
sequel now which is reasons to continue
hosting Republican primary debates in
2024. Mary guys you can watch pop
culture crisis on YouTube at 3 P.M
Eastern noon Pacific time go subscribe
to the channel and if you want to follow
me on Twitter or Instagram it's Mary
archived on both I will be on pop
culture crisis tomorrow yeah we'll see
you guys there is on YouTube Michael
always a pleasure thanks for sitting
through that uh that was I feel bad it's
like we went through uh combat not
really it feels like we experienced some
group trauma yes we'll be able to look
back on are you gonna Read Super chats
that was the Super Chat it was the uh
you know my favorite part of the debate
it was the beef sticks and the scotch I
thought that was the highlight of the
device I call it bison sticks
technically meat sticks meat sticks yeah
it's it's a it's a it's a conundrum when
there's big moments like the debates
where we would normally do super chats
in the members only but the debate ends
at 11 and I have to be up at 7am so it's
just like I have my limits it was hot
hot heat thanks for sitting through it
having a good time what's up Serge yeah
wow that was a lot uh I don't keep you
guys too long I'm search.com I'm looking
forward to Miami it'll be good uh just
so everyone knows in order to watch that
you do have to get become a member on
timcast.com just so everyone is aware uh
yeah but we're gonna we're gonna put out
a video like basically well so I was
inspired by Michael because I watched
the video of you guys talking about
backstage and the issues YouTube was
giving you yeah and then basically what
happens for us with this with the the
show we're doing is
you know we're like yeah we'll do the
show live or whatever and then there
were questions of like okay we're gonna
have people in the audience they can
yell things what do we do about that and
I'm like I don't know and they're like
okay well what subjects you know because
like YouTube has their rules or whatever
and I'm like I think we're for the most
part fine to debate it and they're like
what if they're swearing I'm like we're
gonna be in a room with hundreds of
people who can yell whatever they want
yeah yeah that's way better yeah you
prioritize the room and then the TV show
it's not that it's that you can get a
troll you can get antifa yeah and then
they say they then to sabotage and I'm
like
you know this probably ends up working
out best in terms of helping timcast
grow I know I know like it would be
great if we could give the show away for
free but it was really expensive and I'm
like well we'll make it a members only
thing which makes the show better but
the full podcast will be on all podcast
platforms it's just that the live
portion yeah I understand because then
we're like we have more control over if
something happens in a live event right
right it takes one word and then those
Masters of the Universe zap you down
well so the other issue too is like
Public Square sponsoring it and I'm like
you know if if someone's sitting in the
front row just is trying to screw with
us yeah yeah and then we lose the whole
show because of it yeah is it better to
do the live show members only but then
upload it after the fact where we know
we're good totally it's I think there's
one is one of the reasons Joe Rogan
stopped going live I think it is the
only reason yeah but well yeah so anyway
everybody did the shout outs we're gonna
go and go to bed now
I'm gonna have another beef stick yeah
grab another one there's one right there
thanks for hanging out everybody
seriously thank you guys so much and
we'll see you all tomorrow